foreign
[Music]
breakfast
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
of the Champions chess tour with a new
format and new people in the studio we
can promise you even more action more
time travel and more of the best chess
players in the world so it's a big
pleasure to welcome all of you to the
very first day of the air things Masters
off
the king can't move wait wait wait wait
wait this move is breaking the rules
[Music]
it just looks glorious
he's done that there we go the Avalanche
continues
[Music]
there's a big threat on the board Magnus
Carlton is furious it's going straight
for the kill Wesley so has blundered
he's blundered his Knights white king is
trapped this is
Carlson showing his genius
and more details it's incoming and this
group of Chess experts will be here
every move of the way to guide you
safely through the air things monsters
for my right Grandmaster David Howell
International Master Tanya and
Grandmaster Roberts all the way from the
U.S a big welcome to the awful Studio
Robert thank you Kyle it's a true
pleasure to be here and what an exciting
day for the first time Champions just
for now on chess.com how excited are you
it's great to have the Chess World
unified all the best players taking part
in the same tournament couldn't be more
exciting
David chess24 and chess.com now unified
to create this
War for online chess this is a big day
for chess it's a big day for everyone
for the fans of the the players for
everyone at home but as you say it's the
biggest for chess itself we want to grow
the game and the players we've amassed
world-class players here it's going to
be an exciting week Antonia with the new
Champions chess tour format what can the
fans expect it's going to be so much fun
Kaya we've got a fresh mix of players
the format promises to have twists and
turns dramatic stuff so expect the
unexpected the third season of the
Champions Chester introduces a whole new
format and by the end of the year we
will have an Undisputed champion
the Champions Chester is back with more
incredible chess two million dollars in
prizes the biggest online price fund
ever and a thrilling brand new format
the 2023 tour begins with six elite
events taking place between February and
September each event features an open
qualification system with qualifiers and
players looking in 56 players to the
main events where they will be grouped
into three divisions and compete for 235
000 in prizes
victory in the first division in any of
the six events will secure a spot in the
eight players Champions chess tour
playoffs in December
players will also accumulate Tour
leaderboard points across the six events
and another hundred thousand dollars in
prize money and the unsecured playoff
spots will go to the top leaderboard
finishes
at the end of the year we have 17 days
of incredible chess beginning with the
playoffs from which just four players
will advance to the Champions chess tour
finals a single elimination bracket
together the playoffs and finals feature
five hundred thousand dollars in prizes
there can only be one in December of
2023 an indisputable tour Champion will
be crowned let the games begin
we can't let the games begin without
introducing our fourth expert in the
studio International Master Ivanka
houska now in the corner to keep control
of everything going on yeah this is
going to be my home for the next five
days I'm gonna keep everyone updated on
everything that's going on and the first
update we have to give everyone is the
eight players we will follow in the
first division this week this is the
lineup for the air things Masters first
division eight players they are spread
out across the world sitting in many
different time zones and looking at this
Eureka who do you hold as the big
favorites well three colossal names just
pop out you have Magnus Carlson who is
just the boss in this kind of format
then we have Hikaru Nakamura he is the
best in online chess and of course let's
not forget Wesley so who has looked on
the tour absolutely Unstoppable at times
and there is also three teenagers in
that pack the youngest gukesh at only 16
years old what chances do you give the
young Indian yeah you know on paper he's
gonna have a tough battle because he is
facing Hikaru Nakamura but don't write
him off because he's just 16 years old
and he was the one who actually finished
first in the planes won six games Drew
three and knocked out the Titan that is
a World Champ former world champion of
Vladimir Crown there fantastic and he
has a tough start though playing at
night in India and he starts off against
Hikaru knock on my own self I mean it's
tough but you know this is the baptism
of fire and at least you know he can
relax because the double elimination
format he can just enjoy his moments in
the spotlight and entertain us with some
brilliant chess yep that's what's gonna
happen you guys now two players were
invited to the air things Masters Magnus
Carlsen for winning the Champions
Chester 2022 and Wesley so for winning
the global Chess Championship everyone
else had to qualify
this is the air things Masters the first
event of the 2023 Champions chess tour
000 in prizes are on the line as well as
a spot in the tour playoffs the air
things Masters began with a play in
Swiss tournament open to all Grand
Masters the top finishers battled in
match pay to determine who plays in
division one with eight players division
two with 16 players and division 3 with
32 players 54 qualifiers through the
play in that was held February 3rd
during the 2022 Champions chess tour
winner Magnus Carlson and the global
chess champion Wesley so who are seeded
into division one of the air things
Masters the main event takes place
February 6th through 10th and features a
dramatic double elimination knockout
format
the winner of division one secures a
spot in the Champions chess tour
playoffs in December they will be joined
by the second and third place finishes
of division one as well as the winner of
division two into event 2 of The
Champions chess tour top division the
Champions chess tour is the biggest
online chess event ever held and it all
starts now with the air things Masters
we will mostly follow a division one
this week in the air things monsters but
there are some huge names actually also
competing in division three and in
division two these are today's round of
matches and look at that David John
napomnia is in their Fabiano cariana how
did they end up in division two yeah
some huge names you mentioned too there
Jana punishi and Fabiano uh Carolina
there's also Vladimir kramnik a former
world champion and those three
specifically they fell at the final
hurdle of the play-ins they did lose the
playoffs they failed to make it to
division one that just shows how strong
how stacked this whole field is and they
will be aiming of course to qualify for
division one next time yeah and and we
have to mention Robert it's a big deal
to compete in division two as well a lot
at stake yeah ten thousand dollars first
place prize they're also a great number
of tour points at stake because the
winners of each division one they make
it through to the playoffs in December
but sort of the the lead leaderboard all
right so you have to pay attention to
that exactly now in all three division
double elimination is the format which
basically means that anyone can lose a
match and still win the whole event but
the second you lose a second match you
are knocked out and this is the bracket
for the first Division and we see the
quarterfinal matchups to the left on the
screen here but Tanya who does the
double elimination format favor okay
with double eliminations it is two
strikes and you're out you've got two
shots at the championship what that does
is it takes away the luck Factor it
seems to favor the player who is truly
the best so the best player has the best
shot at winning the championship uh take
a look at this Magnuson Hikaru the two
big favorites it's odd enough to imagine
them losing one match here you've got to
knock them out twice to have a shorter
Championship yeah that's gonna be tough
but having this extra life that Tanya
says Robert doesn't invite for some more
risk-taking do you think it certainly
does because when you see the field if
you lose it best of four match you drop
down to the losers bracket with best of
two so you may take those risks when you
need to in order to stay in this field
so I do think we're going to see very
energetic and exciting play I all right
you guys so we have qualification we
have double elimination we have a new
time control with 15 minutes plus only
three seconds increment we checked in
with some of the top players to hear
what they think about the new Champions
chest War format
I think the tour last year was was great
in the sense that we had so many young
players who got the chance but now we
get all the top players as well as the
as the young coach which is uh
which I think will be super exciting at
the same time the competition is gonna
be tougher because Magnus Crossings can
be playing basically in all events and
also like our Nakamura is there
a fight I think even for the topless it
won't be easy and there's gonna be lots
of qualifiers to all sorts of Divisions
I think that's also a really good news
for the
subtop chess players failure forcing it
to be whoever the best player wins yeah
also for me it's completely new to play
double elimination like I never tried
that and
um I always thought like if you get
eliminated you're eliminated and now
you're back again it's a little bit a
little bit weird in terms of time
control I think it's a great time
control now the games are a little bit
a little bit faster oh a lot more drama
I guess um still fortunately there's
some increments so you won't see like
super nasty flagging of opponents
especially for a player like me who's
gotten a bit slower over the years in
the passive nine controls those 10
seconds were good to have plus three
seconds it's just gonna be like time
travel all the way so I guess more
players more drama more excitement for
the fans
and the action is about to start
everyone with four big quarter-final
matchups in three and a half minutes the
air things monsters will start and
today's matchups are some big ones
Hikaru Nakamura he's a beast at online
chess and he plays today against the
surprise winner of the qualifiers 16
year old you cash and then the winner of
the 2022 Global Chess Championship
Wesley so against Ralph mamadol and then
the big battle between the teenagers
both at 19 years old alirez of Russia
and Arjun ergai but we will follow the
first game
between the reigning Champions chess
tour winner Magnus Carlsen against a
debutant on the tour Alexa Serana and
David who is this guy what is his
strengths Alexa Serana serrana is Young
and dangerous he's 23 years old he can
beat anyone on his day he's especially
good with the white pieces he's very
well prepared he can play all sorts of
positions and if you get give him a
chance to attack he will go for you the
last time these two faced each other
Serana did take the win he must be
coming in with confidence so the last
time they played Serana actually beat
Magnus Carlsen what happened there Tanya
it was like the world Blitz championship
and it was a win not just the result the
quality of the game Super convincing win
and that's just half the story Alexi
Serrano before taking down the world
champion also beating karunakamura also
be done you'll do both a very dangerous
opponent today for Magnus I actually
heard you before the show Robert you
call him the upset King is that what
Alexis Serrata is all about just
offsetting the big gear guns well he
upsets the people that he beats that's
for sure but he's also underestimated by
the public he is not quite 2700 in fide
classical rating but he has beaten the
likes of Gujarati and chakra mamajoro in
lengthy matches in the chess.com Global
Championship so with the names that
Tanya mentioned as well he has who's who
of names at his uh victim list yeah
and if you do look at the head-to-head
stats though there is no doubt Magnus
Carlsen is a favorite at 32 years old
today against the 23 year old Alexey
serrana ranked as number 70 in the world
Magnus Carlsen still world number one so
what is it about for Serana today to be
able to win a match over four rapid
games against Magnus Carlsen well I feel
that Alexa is Serana he has to start off
well we know that Magnus has been guilty
from time to time of starting slowly
Magnus offer needs a bit of time to feel
his way into the into the competition he
mentions he's getting a bit older now
the new time format he might need some
time to adapt Serana is on fire he
played so well in those plays so I feel
the first two games are critical for him
yeah and only 45 seconds until they
played the very first game of the 2023
Champions chess tour season it must be a
special feeling to start off the season
the very first game you know black
papers you know anything can happen what
do you expect from Magnus with the white
pieces in the first game
Kyle I'm looking forward to see what he
brings in the opening we've seen Magnus
try out these absolutely crazy openings
offbeat stuff previously in the
Champions Chester but will he take that
chance against a player like Alexi
Serrano who's so well prepared and it
just might be the strategy that he's
looking at now Serana is known to be a
doctor petition with the white pieces
his prep is second to none I'm actually
expecting Magnus to blow out an opening
surprise in this one really do you agree
Robert I think so because Serana is that
well prepared patch him off guard that
might be the strategy and what could
that be what would the catching him off
guard mean David it could mean anything
for Magnus Carlson I don't think we'll
see something like the bomb cloud or one
F3 you know openings that he's
experimented with on the tour but uh
something early that will get to Serana
out sir thinking on his own just maybe a
different Pawn structure and Magnus does
start this quarterfinal with the white
pieces I think that is huge for him we
mentioned Serana is uh blisteringly good
with white so it does feel like Magnus
Rawl since I sometimes I think the first
few moves will be quite classical quite
normal and the surprises will start a
bit after that and we see Magnus Carlsen
is ready in his secret lab chair not
sitting in at home in Oslo he is I hear
rumors visiting a friend in Canada
the chess bras well known to the public
of course and well they've been posting
on Instagram stuff I feel like we can
let that surprise you I agree yeah so
he's actually playing from Canada Magnus
Carlsen quite early in the morning for
the world number one getting ready for a
game number one so remember it is best
out of four rapid games to decide each
of these matches if they are tied after
those four rapid games then we will head
straight to
Armageddon tie breaks to decide who goes
through to tomorrow's winners
semi-finals and who is knocked down to
the losers brackets and a big smile on
Magnus calls in space is that area
Council that we see
so he's got a supporter in the
background Eric Hansen is not playing in
any of the divisions uh is he no not
that I know of uh I'm not sure if he
played in the uh planes Eric Hansen but
either way uh Magnus this is the first
time we've seen him arrive early for a
game on the tour in ages so it's good to
know he's got his tech support with him
for a cheerleader all on board I think
it's a really crucial Point how rested
Magnus is for this first game he's
traveled over the weekend he's in Canada
right now we also saw him at the end of
Tata steel he looked absolutely spent so
it's going to be a lot about recovery
and energy yeah how would you say that
Magnus carlsen's formats we've seen him
in the rapid and left world championship
of lately and in the total steel he was
on a tear at the end of time to steal he
struggled in some of the earlier rounds
he lost two games in a row unexpected
from the world champion at the end when
he needed his best form he found it
that's scary news for Alexis surround
yeah but this is rapid the chess and it
is a faster time control that we have
been used to the two first season of the
Champions chess story so we have had 15
minutes plus 10 seconds increment this
year is only three seconds increment and
how big of a difference is that David
that's huge there's far less margin for
error with the 10 second increment you
can kind of lose your orientation uh in
the position just for a few seconds and
kind of recompose yourself this one is
purely about Instinct three second
increment disappears so fast and we will
see some uh kind of real calamities on
the chessboard once the players tick
down on the clock so um yeah it will be
about who adapts first and it might
favor actually those who played in those
plays like Serana Magnus he's coming to
this fresh his last games were at Tata
steel seven hour time control very very
different uh type of game there and uh
I'm expecting Magnus to be okay he's
very experienced online of course as
well but uh Serana maybe that's
something he can play on the clock and
the matches should have started
obviously some technical issues here at
to get the 2023 season kicked off we do
not have an image of Alexa Serrata but
he should have arrived and should be
ready to kick off the season with a
match against Magnus Crossing do you
think this is big for Alexei Tanya to
play Not only a game but a match for
games against Magnus huge opportunity
for Alexa in the Champions Chester it is
his debut in the tour it is a platform
that he hasn't had the chance to
Showcase his results in in the playoffs
he beat Fabiano caruana and what a match
that was he was he had to win on demand
and then beat him in the Armageddon and
as David you were mentioning having that
practice in to stop the first round
where often things can be shaky I think
this matchup has huge potential for an
upset we also look at well the price
fund of the Champions Chester now for
players like Magnus and Hikaru whatever
that means it's 100x for a player like
Serana financial support we've seen
breakout moments for these teenagers on
the Champions chess store now whether it
was Prague whether it was Arjun in the
previous editions you know these are the
moments that these players are waiting
for and it could be Serrano's day today
yeah we've seen huge moments where as
you mentioned if you catch pragnananda
beating Magnus on the tour would it be a
huge deal for Alexa today to to win the
match against Magnus it certainly would
be and let's say he does have some
accolades to his name he won the
European online Championship back in
2020 uh he beat Anish giri and David
Navarra in that tournament he knocked
them out of the bracket so it's not like
he's incapable of taking down Magnus
Carlsen it's just a Herculean task for
him so Alexi great success in the past
this would be his lifetime achievement
yeah
and we are waiting for the first game to
start hopefully minus Carlsen with the
white pieces will make his first move
very soon you guys are hinting that we
could maybe see some surprises should we
have a little bit of a bet what opening
move do you think we'll see on the board
I think Magnus will stick to something
he knows and trusts I suggest one E4 how
about you guys that's
that's funny for David playing safety
with one beat three oh okay I'm gonna go
with the Catalan I think Magnus Carlson
use it to success in the world
championship why not again here in the
Champions chess Tour all right what
about you yeah you're not getting out of
this all right all right you said I said
one E4 okay so I'll go on D4
let's see and it looks like now Magnus
Carlsen is leaning towards the screen
does that mean he is getting ready to
make that first move
or is there still some technical issues
and while we wait I should mention that
these two just uh kind of unofficially
online just in some friendly games they
have had very long matches I remember
once staying up till 2 3 A.M in the
morning watching Magnus play Serana I
think they played nearly 100 games in
that one session and it was all so
Magnus could try and adopt sir he did
succeed eventually at like 4 a.m in the
morning but uh it just shows how much
these two love chess and how practiced
they are in the art of online chess and
if we do have anyone new to chess
watching adopting in chess what's that
mean that means winning 10 games in a
row so impressive stuff I think that was
bullet chess very different than this of
course but uh yeah so Ronald did get
some knocks into he did get some wins
under his belt in that one fantastic
all right uh let's hope the first game
starts uh very very soon
um this is the first day of the air
things Masters we are starting off with
winners quarterfinal matches and the
winners of today's matches will go
through to the winners semi-finals
tomorrow but the losers they're not
knocked out because of this double
eliminations the loser is they go down
to the losers bracket to play loser is
round one tomorrow would it be a huge
shock if Magnus calls me already on day
two is on the losers bracket I think it
would be more surprising to the public
than it would be to me because Alexis
Serana is that talented he's that good
and he's beaten the likes of as Tanya
said do Bob Nakamura Carlson in
consecutive rounds in the world Blitz
now different type patrols mean
different games more or less but you
still have those results to your name
that is still a huge accomplishment and
I think Serana can do it I I really hope
Magnus Carlson is paying these guys well
I'm on Hamilton and foreign
for Magnus wow even the best need a bit
of help sometimes so we have both the
chess bras together now with the world
number one Magnus Carlsen is there
actually like a chess Bra House yeah
there is that sounds like a lot of fun
what I wouldn't give to you to be there
right now
um I think that's in Toronto Robert you
maybe know better yeah they moved it
recently I believe they are in Toronto
now and well it's clear that the move
may have messed with their Tech a little
bit but Magnus smiling all of them happy
and the chess Bros I mean they're very
well known to the community and
hopefully they are toned down some of
the electro music and how the partying
because Magnus needs to focus today and
it is quite early in the day so maybe
the partying hasn't started yet a big
smile on Magnus
Toronto and the big chess bra house
getting ready for his first game both
the chess Bros haven't I left the room
so that must mean we should be about to
start and now we also have Alexa Serrano
joining us very nice to see him as well
there's such a contrast between the two
players I don't think I've seen Magnus
this happy before the start of the Run
that's true I don't think I've seen him
arrive on time for a run too to begin
with actually a morning round a morning
round and Serana they're looking super
focused yeah
I've heard that surround is playing from
Serbia I'm not sure
um about that but either way he's so
good so quick over the board online even
faster
and uh I think we'll be about to start
any second now
I can't wait I feel like this turns away
I feel like I'm looking at a passport
photo I've surrounded there right like
someone take a photo get him that visa
and let him get on his way but he wants
this match to start I think the Jitters
start settling in and once you have to
sit and wait once those first moves are
made it's just chest to focus on yeah or
a mug shot
guilty of playing some great chess so
let's say Serana he uh qualified from
the big Swiss and the play-ins that was
played on Friday knocking out some huge
names such as Fabiano caruana and
earning his books here in the air things
monsters to play a quart final match
against Magnus Carlsen
it's long overdue and let's hope the
first moves come on the board very
shortly it is 15 minutes on the clock
for each player three seconds increment
after each move so they will have to
adjust a little bit from being used to
10 seconds increment on the tour can
they how long kind of the thinking
breaks can they allow themselves David
um during these rapid games you don't
want to be going into the tank for too
long early on you have to really limit
yourself to these really short things
you have to trust your instinct a lot
more than you do in classical chess
sometime for calculation but then the
top players do that very quickly too so
I do feel that whoever gets off to the
quicker start will have an early
advantage in the first games of the day
but uh yeah we'll see it looks like none
of the quarterfinals have yet kicked off
so we will
uh impatiently await I get a rumors it's
getting very close so he is the reigning
champion in the Champions chest or both
last season and the first season Magnus
Carlsen can he win it a third time it's
not decided until December who is the
Undisputed champion this is only the
very first game the beginning of the
Champions chess store 2023 and the
beginning of the year thanks monsters
I'm so excited now to see what will be
Magnus Crossing will he and he's you
know he's sat there now for almost 15
minutes
do you think he's changed his mind over
those 15 minutes or do you think he's
been his mind has been set on an opening
move
the first game he kind of knows what he
wants to do already but as the March
progresses we've often seen him in
interviews say that he sort of takes the
decision on the Fly between rounds so I
think he has it in mind what he wants to
start with and we've been talking about
how Serana is a dangerous opponent but
guy it's also so hard to bet against
Magnus on any given day as you said the
reigning the defending champion of the
Champions Chester possible world
champion World Blitz Champion War rapper
Champion how to call him an underdog no
Magnus is the heavy favor we all know it
but Serana will have to push that all
aside focus on the objective moves he
has a chance that's all you can ask for
when you're playing Magnus Carls yeah
well I was about to say has Serana moved
in the last five minutes he finally did
it's not a passport picture this is a
live shot of him meanwhile Magnus
Carlson going for the maximum approach
of snacking off during the game he gets
it right and here we go yay and I am the
first one with the right move you guys
yay we have started this is the
Champions Chester in 2023 but here we go
Robert was also correct with his
prediction
Good Start what are we seeing on the
board you guys so this is one of the
main lines of the Catalan opening this
is uh played by a bunch of top players
in the world seemingly everyone has it
in their repertoire right now white
tries to occupy some of the center but
black is Rock Solid look at Black's Pawn
structure in the middle um it's what we
call the triangle uh Pawn set up just
controlling lots of squares black does
have one problem piece in these
positions it is that black Bishop the
light Square Bishop on C8 tends to
struggle to get out it's often a battle
of the middle game that we will about be
about to see of whether black can
activate that piece and this is still
very well trodden uh this path what do
you guys think uh who's this gonna favor
star wise well Magnus we saw him employ
the Kaplan so much in the world
championship and ever since then uh in
the match against janaponishi and it
seems to suit him really well I think
the fact that he's chosen such a
Mainline Theory against Serana it shows
a lot of respect for his oppon as well
the Catalan you can't fault that line we
see it super trendy at the high level I
think it's a it's a very wise choice by
Magnus taking on someone as strong as
Serana and I think Serana has played
this very well we're still in standard
opening fair about this move Knight bd7
the last move played developing the
Knight is less common than simply
casting the king so that may seem like
an innocuous move but it begs the
question what is the idea is there
something slightly different a Nuance a
wrinkle that Magnus has to take into
account and I believe David that's why
he's thinking yeah it has forced Magnus
to think for himself for the first time
in this game he could as you mentioned
there Robert just automatically Castle
the white king to safety just say okay
what is your idea and that would be
going back to more typical Waters but is
there a difference
uh now Magnus Carlsen adapting to this
rapid format he spent a long time over a
minute on a very standard position I'm
predicting that he will cast it as king
I just don't see what else for white
simply but uh Magnus will he come up
with a more creative approach well 97 as
you mentioned isn't the most popular
move in fact black does go shark Castle
instead which is perhaps what Magnus was
expecting and to just give you some
perspective you've got over 450 games in
shot castle and just about 100 games
with this move that Serana has chosen
and blitzed out shows good preparation
from Alex Seaside now once again Magnus
could decide to go shark Castle which is
the most popular move in this position
about 158 games here or play the move
Bishop F4 as I can see in my database
with only two games Magnus is definitely
in a new position right now so these
seem to be the two most logical moves
either castling the most standard
approach uh or Bishop to F4 I would be
shocked if Magnus didn't Castle I guess
the idea behind this one Tanya is to
free up the square on D2 for the White
Knight but there we go we see on the
live board he has played it getting
ready to park the Knight on D2 which is
actually its dream square and uh after
black castles I'm I would be shocked
again if Magnus doesn't go for that but
uh now Knight bd2 would support a pawn
push and uh looks like on my board we've
seen something really creative from
Magnus it hasn't popped up just yet but
uh this would be what I would go for if
I were white let's uh go back to the
players and what has Magnus got up his
sleeve well you said creative so I'm
guessing it's Harry the H Pawn that must
be it and it comes from the school of
Daniel dubarb dubov was one of the
trainers for Magnus Carlson during his
world championship matches and dubov is
kind of the king of the Catalan he loves
this opening he plays it with great
effect so H2 to H4 throwing that pawn up
the board it doesn't have an immediate
thread but it just can be a bit scary
for black to deal with I see it yeah
there you go uh Roberts he's definitely
been hanging out with Daniel dubov a bit
too much recently Magnus Carlsen uh the
white king now has the question to
answer long term does it Castle short
does it Castle on the king side now that
you've started pushing pawns on that
flank or do you just stay in the center
keep your opponent guessing and that's
something that Kai has mentioned in the
past especially last season on the tour
it's a definite Trend at the top level
to keep your opponents guessing to kind
of play a bit risky and leave your king
in the center but uh yeah the idea is
clear you want to start stepping forward
even further this thing very flexible
with white and if Serana isn't careful
maybe a king size attack a bit later on
and you definitely have to watch out for
that this is ambitious play by Magnus
and we see Serana go for the option if
B6 still keeping flexibility in the
center at some point I am expecting a
pontree to try and open up some files
your opponent goes for the flank attack
you try to open on the center try that
on Castle King put pressure on that and
as the pieces develop I think the way
for black hair David is often to just
take out the top of the bishop on CA get
it to B7 trade the pawn on C4 pick that
pawn up put your knight on D5 and try to
create play in the center as long as
White's king is not castled yeah so this
uh looks like it's a very logical plan
instead Serana has developed his bishop
and uh okay we're waiting for Magnus to
move now what do we think is he gonna
Castle is he gonna decide is he gonna go
left right King side Queen side is he
just going to leave it even longer and
maybe advances Pawn in the center uh so
many questions
it does look very kind of surprising to
me that Magnus has gone for something
this provocative it feels like just
casting your king you know play all the
simple moves first it's the first game
of the day it's a morning round but uh
what do you think of this Robert
something I like to point out is that
Knight on D7 right from the queen it's
dominated by The Pawn on D4 so when
there's a pawn three squares away from a
knight the Knight is in some trouble so
I do like the Contours of the position
for white because that black Knight's a
bit passive so playing the E4 it's a
very common it's a topical idea but you
offer some trades and that's usually
good for the side with less space that
Knight on D7 the Knight F6 fighting for
the same squares called Superfluous
Knights thanks to Jeremy Silman so I do
think we'll see a series of trades in
the 997 will become a happier piece yeah
finally the knights can start to breathe
and it would have a nice Square it could
attack the White Queen for example but
okay what is Magnus Carlson done he
didn't automatically recapture let's go
back to the game because I was certainly
expecting an automatic take on this uh
E4 square but instead of capturing this
spawn Magnus says no I'm going for the
attack he brings this Knight forward of
course this Pawn will disappear long
term it's now attacked four times the
white Bishop is open towards it but uh
he's also hinting at a potential attack
on this square look how the Queen's
Envision long long x-ray vision there is
potentially going to hit the H7 pawn and
Serana doesn't even blink he's playing
so quickly against this really creative
idea he plays C5 again if your opponent
attacks one side
fight back in the center the bar is
really liking it for Magnus yeah the
evaluation bar we should mention on the
side there on the left of the board up
on white side yeah surprising to me
especially considering Saran is playing
so quickly feels like he's in his home
preparation somehow but
um we've got to trust the engine from
time to time and
with which the players are blitzing out
their moves it seems as if they know
what they're doing but this is a brand
new position it's never happened before
so they are playing over the board this
move by Magnus going Knight to G5
attacking on e4 and now he blocks off
the center blocks off that bishop and B7
this Pawn Advance is a very typical way
of getting back to the position after
black has made the move C5 you want to
keep it blocked and you want to keep
pressure on e4 I like this approach of
not allowing black to capture on D4 and
opening up the center yeah he's opening
it in a way that could potentially be
favorable for white he's saying okay we
can open it up but on my terms and what
do we think is this involving a second
Pawn sacrifice temporarily maybe we have
to jump in and show some lines here
Robert I think so because it looks like
after D5 black has that square under
control you can start taking that pawn
on D5 and that has just happened e65 was
played white has to take back with the
pawn and if we get some trades on that
square white will then castle queenside
at long last and black we have two Pawn
bonds but white has the initiative the
momentum is the favor there's a pin down
the default the E4 Pawn will be hanging
maybe there's some better moves along
the way I mean castling King was now
strong is just bringing the Rook to D1
but either way we see how quickly
White's Pieces come into the flow of the
position yeah and just to go one or two
moves further if the black Bishop drops
back we can for example take this Pawn
simply with our Bishop and look at this
already devastating threats on the board
this is a huge threat of Checkmate the
black king not entirely safe and
actually I don't really see how to
prevent this and this could be really
dangerous already and this is the
current position of course we're waiting
to see if Serana does take this Pawn
there is a threat however of stepping
forward one square to trap the black
Bishop so uh already huge questions for
Serana to answer wow what a star you
guys to the 2023 season Magnus Carlsen
maybe about to uh Castle opposite sides
yeah that's very likely yeah it's going
to bring some action now we want you
guys at home to join in the conversation
to join us here in the studio and you
can do so either uh participating in the
twitch chat or by tweeting us using the
hashtag chess Champs we want to hear
your questions your comments we want to
know who you're rooting for and we want
to see your selfies as well so share
them using the hashtag chess Champs and
actually during this tournament the air
things monsters every day we're gonna
give out an air things device to one of
you sharing a selfie on Twitter using
the hashtag chess champ so go ahead and
show us your face we want to see it
yeah and talking of faces we see Magnus
in deep concentration right now on the
camera he I think is trying to hide his
excitement here Magnus for sure he's got
in a brand new idea you mentioned
earlier Tanya we've never seen this
position before and uh he's used it and
really kind of uh it's of course an
important game but uh Serrano wouldn't
have expected this he wouldn't have been
expecting Magnus to go straight for his
throat uh suppressing stuff surprising
stuff that I think Magnus is super happy
with the way the opening has turned out
and we've been talking about this white
Pawn on D5 and how black can capture it
it might be the only way forward uh
David this threat that you pointed out
of D6 and look at the serrana chooses
another part of locating a square for
the bishop
with the move Knight to H5 and the bar
hits it yeah yeah the bar hates this
move we have to try and figure out why
of course it's not just because Knights
on the rim are dim that could be one
explanation of course but it must be
something concrete something specific to
this position that makes the engine hate
this position I hate this last decision
so much by Serana I'm trying to figure
it out it feels like white has a bunch
of ways to create a double attack but no
Magnus just takes the time out and drops
this bishop back what do we think of
this movie the problem was it was a one
move threat the Knight attacked the
bishop on F4 the bishop simply slides
away from the attack and this Pawn E4 is
going to be won by white if you try to
push your Pawn up from F7 to F5 to give
it the opponent's best friend another
Pawn they then the E6 square is
vulnerable the Knight can simply hop in
there that wins some material for white
it's a fork that wins a rook for just
the night there so white would have the
edge I feel like Knight H5 it kicked the
bishop back the question is then what I
don't know the answer to that question
yeah I don't think Serana knows the
answer to that question either normally
if you create a threat your opponent
answers it then you should be able to
quickly show the rest of your plan but
uh yeah as Robert says this looks like a
bit of a one mover and suddenly white
will capture this Pawn with any piece
you can take it in four different ways
next move and again the threats persist
this king is about to come under a huge
attack
looking good for white I've got to say
and sometimes we disagree with the
engine the evaluation bar sometimes it's
hard to understand why the computer says
certain things here it's quite logical I
feel Lux Pieces Just Don't Look ready
for the action in the center most of
them are passive and the only piece
that's stepped away and out of the first
two ranks is this horrible Knight on H5
which will be forced to retreat at some
point to a more defensive square but has
it gone all wrong for Serana here in the
opening or do you think this is part of
his plan I think it's gone completely
wrong for him because Magnus has control
over the position sometimes you have an
advantage but there's only one series of
moves that leads to that edge here all
of White's pieces are on great squares
black is you know one piece activated
like David said but it's on the rim not
doing much now the bishop slid away so I
believe with only one Pawn to his name
and that pawn is likely to fall soon
this is not a good position for Lexi
Serana
yeah and I think he's starting to
realize the seriousness of uh his issues
here his problems uh he's been tanking
for a while and wow Robert he goes for
the move move you suggested logical but
it does come at a cost and Magnus jumps
in instantly he doesn't uh hesitate to
drop his Knight on that beautiful E6
square that is a fork you gotta move the
Queen the queen would be more valuable
of the two pieces she runs away but uh
here Magnus again spoiled for choice
that white knight Is So Glorious so
beautiful do you even trade it for a
rook yes you were material but maybe you
want to keep it on that square we call
it an octopus Knight with its tentacles
all over the board that white knight is
a real thorn in Black side and I
wouldn't be shocked if Magnus just
ignores it just castles Queen side and
says okay the attack continues
and Zach always has to watch out for a
G4 break we see the spawn chain in the
center this E4 Pawn being guarded by
this F5 pawn and you want to break that
and has he gone it does it he does it
instantly uh but he doesn't care about
the king safety he says I'm coming for
your King instead G4 and I see the eval
bar loves it on the board this has
exploded already hitting that night
hitting that pawn if you capture on G4
all white ones is to take on e4 and hit
that pawn on H7 and it's really all
about the black king that Knight on E6
is way worth more than an exchange yeah
this night is uh one of the most
beautiful pieces I've seen in a while
and uh serrana he's facing an attack
he's about to drop drop some material it
just looks right I mean I want to say
hopeless but not quite yet it does look
really difficult for him though the only
alternative to that is dropping back the
night but that's an admission of defeat
you've kind of wasted a bunch of Tempe
with that night move and there'll be
ideas of hitting the black queen with
the bishop there'll be ideas of just
taking a pawn opening up a line for the
white Rook later in the game and uh just
the problems they're adding up they're
building and no salvation here it's one
of those moments I think you have to
take the pawn and pray yeah like I'm
just going to take what's being offered
to me and hope I can survive it it's not
looking good as we're noting the E4 Pawn
will drop you can at any moment take
this Rook on f8 but you don't need to do
that but if we do a quick material count
that's the thing is currently white
would be down two pawns you're likely to
win one back right away and even if you
do eventually take that Rook on a fade
it will be a minor piece and one Pawn
for a rook that is four points for five
that's not an insurmountable lead at
least in terms of material so there are
chances for Serana he will need to play
more quickly and he'll need to trust
himself a little bit but thus far he has
gotten himself in huge trouble yeah huge
trouble and as Robert says you just got
to limit the damage we've all found
ourselves in these situations where we
get kind of attacked in the opening it
all goes wrong we just have to find ways
to survive look for any defensive
resources that you can find and Serana
he tends to be quite good at that he's
quite tenacious as a Defender I found uh
when studying his games so uh he'll just
be looking for ways as Robert mentions
as well to part with material in order
to survive the longer you survive the
more confidence you build up and maybe
the more frustrated Magnus will become
but uh now down a couple of minutes on
the clock as well and with that only
three second increment that we see in
this uh new season of the tour it's
gonna be a real struggle for him all the
pieces still on the board only a few
points have disappeared so still very
tense still some chances but he needs to
speed up Magnus looks anything but
frustrated right now he is definitely
enjoying this position a lot he's got
everything it's like a drink Outland for
him the opponent has got about six
minutes Serana down to six minutes on
the clock a really difficult position to
defend already uh this has gone all
wrong for uh for Alexi it's not looking
good on the bar or on the clock for
Alexa Serana in the first of four games
in the other matches we could see the
evaluation bars roughly to the middle so
more 10 start maybe in the other
matchups yeah it does look like maybe
the bar is slightly in uh nakamura's
favor that was a really fascinating game
we'll keep you guys updated if the
results come in there and uh we'll
mention some highlights a bit later but
yeah this one looking difficult what's
your philosophy Robert Tanya when you
were really struggling when you know
your opponents almost got it in the bag
but you have to survive you have to
fight back
do you want to take this one sure I will
take this one I think that Serana is a
speed demon he is really resourceful
when he even is down to his final
seconds he has great experience in
rapping and Blitz time patrols so at
some point he's just take was offered to
him and run with it he did just take
this Pawn on G4 he is up two pawns at
the moment it's not like there's an
immediate Checkmate or even an immediate
devastating threat so his position is
worse he acknowledged that you could see
it on his face but it's not that
terrible so as long as he can show up
and prevent the immediate threats he
does have a chance in this game and we
see Magnus just take this Pawn on e4
with the bishop creating a threat
against the HM Pawn but the evaluation
bar is taking a little bit of a dip a
knight can come out to F6 there is
activity for blacks pieces and that's
the best news of all yeah and uh at
least his next couple of moves are very
natural he did bring a knight to F6 as a
bit of a defensive Rock there blacks
Knights Superfluous perhaps but they do
control and defend cover some really
important squares Magnus eventually
after resisting the Temptation for a few
moves he has gone to grab the materials
so white has won that Rook for his
Knight he's currently one point up if we
do a count but uh yeah it's more about
the peace activity white has nice
centralization black needs to just uh
lock things down and I like this last
move by Serana planting the black Bishop
on D6 the dark Square Bishop blockading
white Central Pawn you cannot allow that
one to advance it would be too strong it
would win the game and uh he seems to
have done a good job of at least
covering things for now holding things
together
do we think Magnus has a breakthrough
now or is he just going to improve his
pieces as we see in front of us I love
that approach he's already up materially
he just brings the last
into the game bring all your toys
three is this
and a rook to E1 centralizing it David
as you were talking about the approach
in such difficult positions I think your
mindset just has to be to survive
another move you just have to make sure
that you're not losing on the spot and
keep pushing your opponent to find ways
because the hardest thing in chess is to
win a winning position we've seen even
Magnus sometimes not being able to do it
uh so that is what Serana is trying to
do he's trying to keep himself in the
game but it's going to be hard this one
uh I like I like that why this Mater
really up and it looks like white has
all the compensation as well why is it
hard to win a winning position but easy
to lose a losing one chess isn't fair
I was yelled at by Henry Carlson Magnus
carlsen's father once in a polite way
because I asked him something about
Magnus he only needs to draw and Henrik
said it is very difficult
and of course it is and it must be even
harder to as you say win a winning
position yeah all of these guys they're
super strong they're here for a reason
they're all beasts and they all defend
extremely well I think that's what sets
the modern generation apart from past
years uh thanks to engines we've all
learned that there are resources in
positions and especially the young
players they're so so resourceful and
Serana still fighting back still
struggling perhaps objectively but at
least he started to advance pawns
towards towards the white king I do want
to mention just a couple of moves ago
the experience of these two especially
in speed chess has show has Shone
through by the fact they both put their
kings towards the corner black took a
time out to shuffle his King into the
corner Magnus even though he's the one
attack with white took a time out put
his King on a safer square and that's
just because later you don't want to
have to calculate checks attacks and
direct threats but uh talking of direct
threats that Rook on E6 now the white
Rook has landed on a square that the
White Knight used to occupy but still an
outpost still defended by White's past
Pawn in the center and of course by his
bishop and even if black trades off that
Rook it will just be replaced by an
equally powerful Pawn Yeah minus has so
many Intruders in the black Camp right
now yeah and uh those intruders are only
going to start eroding the black
position father
um this last move is a bit of a sad one
but I love it though I mean from the
defensive perspective you can't trade
pieces you're just going to lose any end
game you are down material so Rook d8
threatens in a way I put it in air
quotes because it's not a big threat but
Bishop's sliding back to its home Square
hitting the Rook on E6 and the bishop
105 behind it so all of a sudden you
know he's putting up sturdy defense he's
much worse perhaps objectively lost but
he at least he's keeping all of his
pieces connected with one another and
that doesn't allow a Magnus to knock out
blow yep actually everything's defending
each other right now these Knights are
kind of clinging onto each other for
dear life uh this bishop the blockader
of that powerful white Pawn uh It is
Well defended for now well fortified I
do wonder if Magnus can start upping the
pressure I'm not sure whether you have
time to bring your Rook uh kind of
pocket doubled Rooks there instead
Magnus centralizes his Knight wow nice
move and adding even more pressure onto
those two uh kind of most important
Defenders exchanging pieces as well as
Robert mentioned helping uh when you're
ahead on material
yeah I love this move Knight E4 uh that
Knight on F6 with the spin on The d8
Rook you just want to get rid of that
and your task becomes that much easier
you're also hitting that Bishop on D6 uh
that's how you're fighting against the
threat of a bishop to C8 as you were
mentioning uh Robert and I think
everything that Magnus has done so far
seems like Flawless play yeah he just
seems really relaxed I've never seen
magnets like this in the mornings
normally he takes a while to warm up but
he just looks really relaxed and using
this opening idea he's never let Serana
kind of get a foot into this game I was
talking about getting off to a fast
start earlier Serana shaking his head
he's normally ice cold emotionless and
uh Fearless but Serana shaking his head
there he has played Bishop to F4 trying
to trade off these Pieces perhaps these
Bishops will that help him this Pawn has
also been freed up to start advancing in
the near future not right now perhaps
but some calculation to be done for
Magnus
Bishop F4 you can also start thinking
about doing all kinds of trades on F6
and really taking Black's defenses away
the G4 Pawn will fall the 87 Pawn will
be not defended uh I'm expecting a bunch
of Trades of these defensive resources
that Serana has with these two knights
and meanwhile we do see the bar has
swung in nakamura's favor against happen
there yeah some big developments
potentially in that game and of course
we've seen the bar all up in White's
favor in this game too for a long time
now and Tanya predicted the future yet
again and a capture of Black's Defender
that Knight on F6
and it is replaced but that night the
second night will also disappear any
second now the two biggest favorites
could be about to get a perfect start to
the air things monsters Magnus Carlsen
and Hikaru Nakamura the bar is also
going out for another
small favorite we must call him that
Oliver Russia again Sergeant Eric icy in
the first game yeah there is a
definitely the favorite at least on
paper he's high rated in classical chess
Arjun had a terrible event in Vikings a
he didn't win a single game he lost a
number of them but we know what he's
capable of so ordinary guys he finds his
form he can definitely combat other as a
fuja yeah
and also we haven't seen Oliver that
much in action where is this practice
coming from right now and these kind of
formats just demand you to be on the go
from the very start of course alireza
had a very comfortable going in with the
Swiss and the playoffs but uh Arjun
we've seen him on the tour before and
what's interesting is that I don't
remember these two teenagers playing
against each other so this thing could
be the first time this matchup is
happening and alireza was one of the
first in this generation to sort of
break away use world number two and I
mean far ahead of everyone but he sort
of inspired this younger generation uh
to come forward and this change of God
this movement that we're talking about
alireza was right in the front of it and
especially with your fellow Indians
Tonya with go cash with Arjun aragaisy
with Prague nananda there's so many of
them yeah and to think that they're all
the same age it's kind of hard to
imagine but at some point you felt like
alireza broke away and went a little
further and sort of just giving these
other youngsters this inspiration that
they can do it as well and now to see
these two fight against each other I
think it's going to be a big match it
doesn't matter who's stronger on paper
uh arches gonna give a big fight he's
also super good in these speeches faster
formats yeah
so I just love the fact that farouja in
the play ends on Friday he was playing
from his kitchen
I'm curious to follow him a bit later I
wonder if he's uh following the same
recipe for success but uh meanwhile
Magnus planting that White Queen in the
center Black's Bishop is plugging all
the holes uh that dark Square Bishop now
for black but it could be removed at any
moment first Magnus gobbles up a pawn
he's getting ready to throw the white F
Pawn forward to destabilize that black
Bishop in the center and
this one looks like we're coasting now
towards victory for Magnus Carlson and
the Queen the White Queen was over near
the king now it's going near the enemy
King it just took a pawn it's gonna
slide up on the diagonal and go after
the black king on h8 Queen H5 threatens
Checkmate H7 also allows The Rook to
land on E8 in many positions it protects
that square so this is a big problem for
serrana I think he is completely
hopelessly lost I don't say that very
often as a commentator but this position
it's he's getting obliterated in this
one yeah just to highlight the idea that
Robert mentioned there for example if
Bishop takes Pawn is played white can
even give up his Rook for that strong
Bishop in the center and now create that
threat those dual threats actually uh
firstly Checkmate on the H7 square but
now that this black Rook has been lured
away from the E8 Square secondary threat
is just as devastating and this could
spell game over at this point it's hard
to offer any advice for Serana he might
as well play a move such as this one and
ask Magnus to prove uh the win to show
the win because it's inevitable at this
point you just need to find the most
testing way for your opponent uh it's
looking hopeless also down under two
minutes for Serana what does he play he
pushes a pawn forward this doesn't
change anything however he's looking for
counter play he's pushing pawns towards
towards the white king but he's so far
away he needs three or four moves to
create a single threat and uh Magnus
will land a punch before that
and now that he's allowed the Deep on to
stay alive David that pawn can actually
go forward to these six and also
threaten The Rook coming on to the
seventh rank so let's say you stop with
the move Queen H5 it's on the board
you're threatening a mate in one and
Serana has to defend that with the queen
losing control of the D6 Square after
which uh let's say queen goes to G7
defending the mate on eight seven and a
move like D6 would be absolutely
devastating coming in with the Rook on
the seventh Rank and this is Checkmate
incoming uh Serrano's down to a minute
and a half and the clock is not even his
biggest problem yeah we saw it in the
camera a minute ago he was just rubbing
his eyes he's like what happened this
has just been a powerful display by
Magnuson we can't fault Serrano at all
he's uh just not really been given a
chance in this game it's sometimes
happens against the top guys in the
world yeah he was an unfamiliar position
and Magnus was on the attack Serana felt
uncomfortable he brought his Knight to
the rim and it never quite got back in
the game except when it was traded off
the board in a winning position for
Magnus Carlson so this is dominance this
is the world number one player for over
the last decade uh he's showing his
force in game one and he's about to lead
one nil I think resignation and coming
yep I think we have the result Magnus
did get his Rook to the seventh Rank and
Serana has resigned wow 32 moves and
it's over Magnus Carlson he takes the
first punch the first point in the
quarterfinal match against Alexa Serana
the Russian will have to make a comeback
he will have the white pieces in game
two the other matches they are still
playing the first games and we're gonna
jump into the first game between Hikaru
Nakamura the online Beast against 16
year old gukesh the oldest against the
youngest in the air things monster is
actually and the bar is loving it for
Hikaru of Nakamura are you loving it
Robert I am indeed and the reason why is
if you do a quick material count uh
White is down one Pawn but it's
essentially being down two pawns on the
queen side where there are two unopposed
passers and there we go A5 pushes one of
them and then white is up one Pawn over
there on the king side but white is not
creating a pass Pawn because Black's
King is in the way so I believe the
white forces will be distracted we'll
have to run on over to stop the pawns
and then black can then scoop up the
remaining Pawns of whites so I think
this is actually a straightforward
victory for Nakamura yeah Knights are
famously bad as well against these Rooks
against the a h pawns and white knight
is going to be completely paralyzed
stopping that runner on the a file he
does go cash centralize his Knight
heading towards the queen side but yeah
this one it feels like it should be a
matter of time the one uh kind of
potential hurdle here the one potential
banana skin for Nakamura is that all the
pawns disappear you can't allow the
White Knight to trade off all the pawns
uh because a knight on its own for black
would not be enough to deliver Checkmate
thankfully he has four of them left to
those pawns then I don't think ukesh
should be able to trade them all off
what's gone wrong for the young Indian
in this game
I think it's just uh Nakamura at its
best you're facing one of the best end
game players of all time you're pulling
down it was very tense for a long time
earlier but it feels like uh gokesh kind
of cracked at a very uh crucial moment
in Nakamura since then hasn't put a foot
wrong yet should still be able to guide
this one towards Victory his King has
been pushed back however fair play to go
cash he's at least asking questions he's
saying can you win the same game without
your king Nakamura shaking his head I
must say I haven't seen him play from
this location before it's uh different
from his usual uh streaming place I
guess but uh okay shaking his head a
little bit yeah and the bar for the
first time at least slightly showing
some white uh kukesh has stopped those
black porns in their track for now is
there a way to break this what do we
think
well the good news is that one night on
B5 takes care of both of the black pawns
at least for the moment and you see the
Black Knight go back towards the White
ponds you're just trying to keep white
uh excuse me black stuck in place on the
queen side and then black is trying to
go after the Pawns of the king side but
the white king can slide over and save
that pawn and if the pawns get traded
like you're mentioning David that gives
white chances what you need to do is to
limit all four blacks pawns and even if
that costs you your knight you will be
able to make a draw a lone King and
Knight cannot deliver a Checkmate so all
of a sudden Hikaru he's looking a bit
frazzled and maybe he believes that
gokish has a chance yeah and under one
minute now for Hikaru and wow what a
move giving up his night offering that
night as bait and he's counted very well
here he's uh realized it is a race let's
go in and show this night sacrifice
again uh because uh Nakamura now giving
up his night if it's captured it's a
race between this pawn two squares away
from promotion and this night
unfortunately the Knight cannot get back
in time to stop this Pawn from becoming
a queen we mentioned that night
especially bad against these Rock pawns
and it's going to be a new Queen on the
A1 square and uh therefore if the Knight
cannot be captured it must be driven
away and if White Knight if the white
knight runs for example to retreat the
black pawns can start rolling uh once
more what a move Tanya what an idea at
97 I absolutely love it as you mentioned
the knights are the worst Defenders
against the flank pawns and Knight C7
just on pre giving up a whole piece but
the a pawn is super fast and the main
idea of this move by Hikaru is of course
to try to push the beep on to assist the
a pawn uh to queening and he sort of
found the fastest way to Victory and I'm
just thinking very often the players say
that you know what hikaru's Expressions
can be so deceptive and that little head
shake that we just saw by him and then
he plays this fabulous Knight C7
calculating it to Victory I think it's
one of those moments don't go by what
you see with Hikaru yeah he's full of
those expressions which throw us off but
also throw his opponents off and uh yeah
his A4 now is only two squares away that
white knight and that black Acorn based
cancel each other out and finally those
heads uh the Bops I don't know what to
call them Hikaru knows he's winning yeah
and uh yeah this one's a matter of time
and we have another huge result you guys
we were looking at alireza Rosa origin
ergasi saying that it was looking quite
good for alirez of Russia something has
happened here Arjun Eric icy takes the
first point wow and what a way to win I
just looked over at that game if you
want it with the queen sacrifice Robert
yeah it was a beautiful queen sacrifice
at the end so he was able to take game
one a gorgeous play from originara
geisie and his compatriot his friend
Gucci he's struggling now against
Nakamura down a pawn in this end game
and I think looks word deceiving uh
Hikaru Nakamura shaking his head but
when all of a sudden done this one the b
and a pawns they're too far Advanced the
Knight on A6 is shepherding them towards
the other side and I believe that black
will simply get a queen and if that
Queen is stopped then that requires the
white king to dark all the way over over
to the queen side and the black king
will scoop up the remaining white Pawn
so this is an easy finish for hikar
Nakamura at this point yeah and took
cash now down to his final couple of
seconds he needs to move oh he made that
move I think with two seconds left he's
running with the white king towards that
side but there we go I think we have the
result confirmed no way to stop those
pawns from running now the pawns will
become a queen and kakesh gives up
CaRu takes the win it's over another win
for a big favorite Hikaru Nakamura with
the black pieces takes the win against
will have the black pieces in the next
game and he has to make a comeback at
some point remember it is best out of
four rapid games this one is still going
on Ralph mamado against Wesley so this
is game one and the bar is as much in
the middle as it possibly can be I think
it says gonna be a draw they do say that
all Rook end games are drawn and uh this
isn't an exception and here white is a
pawn up but that pawn won't last too
long black won't necessarily actually go
and take that pawn that very far
Advanced White Pawn because it's under
control it's under lock and key the
black king keeps the watchful eye over
it but the black Rook is going to go and
restore material balance by taking
another Pawn look at this F7 Now by
Wesley so he's trying to hint that he'll
make a new Queen but uh he's not quite
quick enough it is it's becoming a race
uh any chance here for either side to go
wrong wow that white F1 blinking you
miss it it's disappeared and uh how is
Wesley gonna hold the draw here suddenly
he's the one to pulling down that was
quite a turn around really quick but
lucky for Wesley here that the king is
attacking the H5 pawn and The Rook from
f8 cuts off the black king will come to
defend its g-pawn which is advancing and
this is going to end in a draw it's
trickier than you would expect and
that's why I brought the king back if he
took that pawn on H5 what's happening it
seems suddenly he's winning oh no it's
not the depth issue sometimes you know
it freaks out it goes somewhere but the
king steps back to F4 Wesley understands
as long as he picks up the G2 Pawn the
game is immediately a draw because a
king in H Pawn that lone Position will
be a theoretical Droid there's no way
for black to dislodge the white king
from the corner so that is where
Wesley's aiming we're getting just that
yeah yeah this game will end in
stalemate but I can confirm for one move
mamadolf was winning that really he
actually played the right idea but in
the wrong order he could have played the
same idea but stopping the white king
from coming back to blockade this pawn
and uh yeah and games are so tricky I
wrote it off I said it was going to be a
draw it was a draw but there were tricks
in the position Wesley surviving there
wow bit of luck on his side three
matches ended up with winner but in this
one a draw in the first game Wesley so
walks away now five minutes and we will
start the second set of games only five
minutes but before that we have to take
a look at some of the action that
happened in the very first round of the
air things monsters on the 2023
Champions chess tour season this is
today's learning points
and today's learning point is about
bringing all of your pieces to the party
especially when you're trying to attack
this is a position from the game alireza
frugier as white against Arjun eragasi
as black and we mentioned a cool Queen
sacrifice did happen that was all
because Eric icy brought all of his
pieces towards that white king and they
harmonize so well suddenly The Black
Queen jumped out threatening a nasty
Checkmate the white king trapped in the
corner here a rook had to swing over and
defend and Regice he won a pawn with
this queen for Russia reluctant to go
towards the end game and now bringing
another piece into the attack the Black
Knight jumping in hitting the White
Queen if Queen takes Queen this is a
nasty smothered mate the white king
trapped in the corner here of course the
White Queen couldn't do this it moved
away but now another queen Sacrifice by
uh Eric I see now trying to trick the
White Queen into capturing and this
smothered mate idea persists he won a
very nice game it only lasted a few
moves longer than this but if you
combine all your pieces bring them all
in good things foreign
your subscription makes shows like this
possible which is why our twitch
subscribers will never see ads on
chess.com connect your chess.com account
and Twitch account at go.chess.com
connect accounts and bang boom voila
you're done 100 AD free Bliss
forevermore whether you're following our
events on site or on stream type the
command connect in the chat and thank
you for helping bring these shows to
life
take a a twitch break for anyone who is
non-subscribers for everyone else we're
now going to dig deeper into the first
round of the Champions chess store 2023
foreign
[Music]
new time control so much trouble yeah I
mean I was completely gobsmacked you
know so much action so much drama and I
can actually say a lot of it was to do
with clock management to time and uh for
instance alireza farouza against Arjun
erag I see that was so cagey so tense
but uh farooza just let his clock run
down and then what you saw at the end he
just panicked he went hard and it
backfired on him and someone else who
pushed too hard was a good cash he went
really really aggressively against
Hikaru and Nakamura in the beginning but
that went completely wrong because
Hikaru just calmly defended everything
picked up a pawn and won a name game did
we see the players take a little bit of
risks here in the first games definitely
especially from The Underdogs I would
say I mean they really like tried to
push the boundaries they tried to make
the the favorites a little bit unsettled
and to burn time on the clock sometimes
it was a good strategy sometimes it
didn't work as we saw yeah and Magnus a
big favorite if you want his game Hikaru
a big favorite he won his game but Arjun
eragaisy winning against Oliver is that
the one that impressed you the most yeah
absolutely because they really matched
each other I mean that farooja
definitely will be very frustrated by
that game and he will definitely be
going back to the drawing board
and let's take a look at the results you
guys remember it is best out of four
rapid games Magnus Carl's now in the
lead against Alexa Serana
so is Hikaru Nakamura against yukash and
Arjun aragassi against oliveras Russia
Wesley so and Ralph mamadol they are
tied and the second games are coming up
very shortly you guys so get ready for
some more action
we have started this is the Champions
chat store in 2023. what is Magnus
Carlson done he didn't know
so quick
in the center he doesn't care about the
king safety he says I'm coming for your
King instead
all right that was fun you guys we
haven't started how do you feel I feel
great we have some really great clashes
to start the day exciting chess their
whole players are holding nothing back
yeah I mean there was exactly nothing
about holding back no quick draws no
saving anything this was action from the
get-go I mean did you see arjun's game
we got a brief look at it what was that
that was destruction on the board Magnus
from the start with that H Pawn going
forward delivering a Checkmate on
Serrano almost and everything was busted
there all uh this is the kind of Chess
we love and we're getting all the action
that we were hoping for definitely and
we're gonna follow now from the start
game two between origin erigasi now with
the white pieces against Ali Reza furuja
for Russia he has to make a comeback
yeah at some point today because he did
lose the first game and can you imagine
this self-confidence the origin must
have after winning not only the game but
in the fashion he did it yeah not just
winning a really stylish Victory but
also winning with the black pieces in a
Four game match having a win and having
more whites in the remaining games
that's a huge advantage and uh Eric I
see he plays all sorts of openings now
what's going to be interesting for me is
whether he goes again all out attacking
approach which served him so well in the
first game or does he take a Karma
approach I don't think that latter one
will help actually too much against far
Asia because things will get messy at
some point anyway you have to fight fire
with fire but uh that's uh it's gonna be
fascinating his first game was just
incredible both teenagers both 19 years
old do they also have a similar style or
are they very very different kind of
chess players I think they're quite
different I think that Ali Reza much
prefers an energetic play he doesn't
like sitting in passive structures
whereas for origin aragosi he doesn't
mind maneuvering around the board he's
actually quite mature for his very young
age okay okay so what kind of game
should we then expect
is very combative as well he does not
he's not afraid of taking decisions that
blow up the position it really depends
on what the position really demands I've
seen him play at the thought of Steel
chest in India the rapid and Blitz he's
an absolute monster and she's in
speeches we've seen him in the Champions
chess store he really thrives in these
formats and alireza loves fire on the
board arjun's ready for it yeah
you will have the white pieces in this
one in the lead Arjun Eric garci uh is
he one of those players who uh plays
Everything Under the Sun or or does he
have some favorite kind of openings well
when he first burst onto the scene I
felt that he was really kind of an
expert in certain structures certain
types of positions but lately I was
looking at Tata Steel by kanzai he was
playing everything and not once would he
hold back he had a difficult tournament
there I think losing four or five games
but still every game he'd come back and
go for his opponents and that type of
strategy is going to really serve him
well in the long term and uh of course
he had a breakout year last year and
that was due to his Universal Style just
the fact he can play anything and had
the confidence to back it up and uh yeah
I'm fascinated to see the first few
moves should we do predictions again
yeah
I'll keep my D4
am I allowed to copy Kyle because she
was correct the first time I want to
join you this time again 44 yeah or the
D14 yeah yeah I'll go with Knight F3
okay I'll go uh oh you've stolen with
the good ones G3
and uh okay we have uh farouza on our
picture it looks like is that his
kitchen again
uh maybe a change of scenery for alireza
the one thing that thing that hasn't
changed
it's true and then just goes on to blow
up the board yes you might be going to
bed soon it's very late in India so it's
nearing bedtime for him but you are
correct through all the events we've
seen he won the junior speeches
Championship beating nihal sarin in an
epic final it looked like he didn't even
break a sweat wow wow then he also made
it all the way to uh the final and the
Julius bear generation Cup last season
Arjun aragaisi he did lose two Magnus
Carlson but he played a fantastic
tournament to make it all the way to the
final in that one
did he really make his big breakthrough
last year Our Generation it felt like
that it felt like everything he touched
turned to gold in 2022 he won a bunch of
tournaments on the online scene he was
uh steamrolling through some kind of
world-class players and and of course
2023 didn't start off that well for him
but we know he's on a hot streak he's
over 2700 now in classical he's there to
stay and we'll be talking about him both
of these players hopefully for years to
come I really hope for Russia as well
comes back to over the board chest a bit
more in future
um it's been a bit maybe a bit more
mysterious what he's been up to over the
last few months but Eric I see he's been
playing tournament after tournament
after tournament uh barely taking a
pause for breath and that's helped him
improve that's the trick to success so I
went to Tata steel to interview a few
players and many of them would mention
Ali reservous as one of the favorites in
the Champions chest for 2023 and they
would also mention something about
fashion that he's gotten into fashion
lately what is that rumor I think that's
uh the other memes right online people
just say that all the time in the chat
uh he might be into fashion but it's
clear that he's still into the chess and
we do have liftoff so the game is
underway here we go game two you guys
between all the rights of food shop and
Arjun all right I see um he might be
into fashion but you guys should get
into Panda 3 I mean one D4 on the board
I love it nailed it again and uh it's a
London system
are we allowed to boo openings here in
the studio is that because it's a boring
opening I just think that it creates a
situation that is a slower build up you
know it's not going to be a game oh
maybe it'll show differently but it's
usually kind of a calmer start to these
positions yeah I think we're only
allowed to do the London system the
French and maybe the Berlin
anything else is off limits those three
fair game but uh yeah it has made
Furniture pause for thought I'm very
surprised I must confess because Eric
icy has been dabbling in the London
system quite a lot over the last year or
so he's also been playing the job of
London uh many times he used it against
Magnus for example in the world rapid
Championship so uh this surely shouldn't
have come as a surprise if ferrugia was
doing his preparation but maybe he was
just thinking new match situation I'm
down a point I want to play for a win I
can't just choose a solid option I can't
just play for a draw in this one so
farouza fianchetto uh his light squared
Bishop over there on the queen side I
was about to say could we be going
towards a queen's Indian type of setup
but D6 there pushing a pawn just
blocking the London Bishop the white
Dart squared Bishop there very sensible
he's getting ready to bring more pieces
out and just uh keeping Eric I see
guessing here it's very much out of the
Realms of theory here it's just about
who understands the plans the setups
better in the uh ensuing middle game I
also like how flexible both players have
kept their structures black and also
fianchat or the other Bishop I was just
about to say from the King side G6 and
the bishop lands on this long diagonal
white not committing the seat Bond so
here Arjun is deciding whether he wants
to put it to C3 or to C4 for a more
aggressive approach in the center
first we might see Eric icy just get his
King to safety and get the white king
castle with London system players they
follow a tried and tested method here a
system in the opening they just want to
put the white Bishop out maybe on E2 get
the white king castled drop the dart
Square Bishop back and then start
playing chess and then start playing the
game the London system not everyone's
favorite loads of memes out there for it
but hopefully this one will liven up at
some point yep
We are following the second game our
generic icy is in the lead and I've seen
a bunch of your selfies popping up on
the screen as well we do love to see
that you guys joining in on the action
share your selfie on Twitter using the
hashtag chess Champs and every day
during the air things monsters we will
pick a selfie winner of an air things
device it's actually signed by Magnus
Carlsen himself so enter the competition
by sharing your selfie we want to see
where in the world you're watching the
chest from who you're watching it with
is it late at night is it early in the
morning for you wherever you are in the
world share your selfies so if I share a
selfie of who I'm watching with yeah the
three of you yeah do I automatically win
you don't automatically win but you
automatically enter the competition
we'll fix it so that you don't win wrong
we might also be able to hook you up
with an air thanks device I appreciate
that yeah and we'll talk about that more
throughout the event but air quality we
have found in past seasons in past years
that it has had a direct effect on the
players uh the quality of their play and
we've seen Magnus Carlsen play well when
he's got great air quality Anish giri
really lives so he kind of swears by the
air things device so hopefully whoever
gets it in the end will use it to kind
of benefit their chess I mean so
important for chess players with the
online chess playing from their homes to
have good air quality if CO2 levels are
super high it's gonna be hard to
concentrate for sure and something else
that needs air is someone's position and
you see the last movie that was played
the pawn push in the center gives some
air to the black pieces and it looks
like origin he decided to hop forward
with his Knight he's keeping the tension
that's something very instructive in
chess you don't release the tension
until the moment you feel is ready
because you don't just want to take a
piece as it is simply offered but it
this does give black the opportunity to
push that Central Pawn for word and
create an attack towards the white king
so it's going to be an interesting
battle here I think just the type of
position that alireza fuja could hope
for out of the London system yeah and
the debate is always as Robert mentions
when to push this Pawn forward or if to
push this Pawn forward because yes you
can gain some time actually he doesn't
go for this he captures the pawn but uh
after the White Knight steps back the
dot Square Bishop the London Bishop
actually gains in power gains an
influence along this diagonal long term
and unless you can actually go for this
King and Checkmate it then often this is
something that may backfire instead for
Asia slightly surprisingly to me
captures this Pawn this is something we
don't often see uh in the London system
too much now white I'm assuming will
recapture it this way and there will be
a semi-open C file for the white Rook
later still the same issue of this dark
Square Bishop having a watchful gaze
over this diagonal this does happen and
version says okay you've got a slightly
more open position now I'm going to lock
down the queen side I'm going to fix the
pawn structure here Lex Pawn are going
to stay in this formation for I think uh
forever if they can and play will switch
towards the central squares black is
maybe going to plant a knight on this
nice E4 square and start pushing some
pawns towards the white king from your
London experience London system
experience guys uh what do you think is
this
well who's this going to favor this corn
trait I'm surprised I must say
you like what alireza has done with this
Pawn trade and I think it was uh it was
encouraged by white move pushing that a
pawn to A4 and this is the point that I
was going to make David that the Knight
can't jump to B4 as well because white
spawn has all all the way gone up to A4
you don't have to move A3 pushing that
night so the B4 square is a super nice
Square for your knight to land on so yes
you want to trade in the center forcing
white while not forcing but white wants
to pick that pawn up with the c Pawn as
he did but in that bargain you kind of
give up control over this B4 square and
that's what alireza is fighting for so a
nice idea there okay interesting stuff
although I might say that the pawn push
that other is made to push the pawn to
A5 I think that gave white some ground
because just like you're bringing the
Knight into B4 white can bring the
Knight via A3 up to B5 and the big
problem for black is you can't touch
either the c or the d-pawns if you push
the C Pawn you lose the pawn on D6 if
you push the D Pawn eventually up to D5
if the Knight moves out the way then C7
will be a quick Target so I feel feel
like that move A5 was one of those just
small moves that has a big consequence
consequences for both sides certainly
and uh let's go back to the players I do
expect them because this is a more
maneuvering type of battle to spend
quite a lot of time I do notice
especially in the rapid format players
tend to invest their time when there's
lots of different plans to choose from
when it comes to calculation they're so
quick that they make decisions very very
fast and they're usually right so uh
here where there's no right or wrong
answer where it's just a matter of taste
a matter of style and they do tend to
tank for a while so Eric I see now down
three minutes on the clock this is kind
of a reverse of the first game between
these guys when it was far Asia and his
clock handling that cost him but wow
peace sacrifice and honey your first
instinct was what he's given up a bishop
he's London Bishop for two Pawns that is
the bishop that you you just love this
is the reason you play the London and he
gives it up well the idea is clear
you're hitting that Rook on E8 you're
hitting that Bishop on B7 and black has
to answer the question has to give back
some material here do you
there's one interesting idea that does
exist Queen B8 defending that saying
that you take the bishop you take the
Rook on E8 but I get two pieces in
return and it looks like it might be
enough for black I am shocked at this
decision David yeah and if we do a quick
count now we do see that white has
partnered with a bishop a knight that's
worth six points black however has
plotted with a rook and two pawns with
seven so kind of if we do a bit of maths
white should be ahead but top chess
players they often prefer the pieces
rather rather than the rook and pawns
here White's Rooks one of them is okay
on the open C file the other one faster
sleep at home white pawns can't really
advance and often it actually helps
having more pieces here black having the
nine and Bishop because uh if you do
whip up an attack later on two pieces uh
will be better than one and Robert what
do you think of this committal decision
by white well Big Choice from origin era
guys tonight I'm used to trusting him
he's such a strong player that he would
not make the sacrifice so he hadn't
looked at a similar type of sacrifice in
the past but what we're saying certainly
holds true that the two minor pieces can
team up on a square where or on a piece
and Rook is only one piece it's gonna be
difficult to defend so for now I like
White's position I think everything is
nice and neat but I could see a future
where black just improves piece by piece
and then white will not be able to deal
with it because there are no more
Targets in Black's position what are you
going to go after everything is safe and
sound so I do feel like as this game
continues it's a side who has the better
plan that is going to have the advantage
yeah so this one despite the evaluation
bar being roughly in the middle it could
go either way later on and
yeah I I kind of love and hate that
decision
I hate it because I would never be brave
enough to play something like this
myself because it now it's so imbalanced
it's so complex but I also love it from
a Fan's point of view because this one
is going to be anything butter draw this
one it could go either way especially if
as we predict it's very likely at this
point Black's pieces do start to improve
do start to mobilize and whites Rock if
it can't use the openc file it will feel
like a bit of a silly piece so yeah all
to play for in this one all to play fun
black needs to watch out because white
has got a devious threat right now
because white wants to push off that
Knight on D5 with the move like E4
notice how The Queen 98 cannot pick up
that pawn any Focus the Knight on D7 is
hanging and uh then you'll be forced to
move that Knight and White's Rook can
jump to C7 which is why alireza takes
the decision to move the Rook to the
center of the board defending the D7
Knight so that if you do go E4 now the
black queen is free to capture the pawn
yeah mrich capture the pawn and
importantly the Knight is defended so uh
yeah hidden threat though I actually
missed that one Tanya but of course
these top players they do spot those
ideas and nice defensive move there from
farrugia if we talk about white
improving pieces maybe you can finally
utilize this Rook try to start motoring
your pawns up the board you have to use
your pawns remember you do have two more
of them uh if you're white here than
black does but it's not going to be easy
for example if you do move the Rook to
support Paul push black can clamp down
on that one maybe push the F Pawn to
control that square maybe occupy that
square with the queen a bunch of options
and uh yeah it's hard as we mentioned to
get this Rook into its dream post on C7
for now because it's protected by a
knight but watch out for Eric I see
trying to tactically enable that
maneuver a bit later on so we are
expecting this now to be an interesting
uh battle I was gonna ask right before
Air Guys he made those huge decisions if
we should switch games because I could
see on the bars in the other games that
maybe Magnus Carlsen is struggling
against Alexa Serana if you've seen that
game Robert here is I was looking at the
game at the corner of my eye and for
Magnus Carlson he won with the white
piece in game one very convincingly here
in game two it looks like Serana if you
if you didn't show the audience who had
what color you might think that Magnus
Carlsen had the white pieces because
it's just a clear Advantage for Alexa he
is playing very well in the second game
all right
the Hikaru Nakamura so the bar all the
way well it's over to his side against
yukashi won the first game Hikaru
Nakamura and you guys shout out if we
have to switch games but it does sound
like there will be a lot of action in
this one it feels like for now this is
the place to be but we will keep uh keep
you guys updated I should also mention
with Serana in the play-ins he went
seven for seven with white wow and in
the world Blitz he beat Nakamura and
Carlson with white so those are the
games he's banking on he's relying on he
needs to win those ones uh with black as
we saw in in game one of the day he does
struggle a bit he didn't score so well
and his black repertoire maybe not uh as
bulletproof as uh he is with the white
pieces and Carlson just wants to survive
that one but it's going to be an uphill
task Serana doing very well and Serana
is known to be a beast with the white
pieces his preparation the way he plays
once he gets the initiative so it's
definitely going to be a tough one for
Magnus and looking at what we have in
front of us I think it's going to be a
tough one for alireza as well I love the
idea that you mentioned earlier David of
bringing the Rook into the center of the
board with rookie1 and it's been played
the idea is simple you really want to
land that sea Rook on C7 you want to hit
that Bishop the pinned Knight on D7 E4
is a massive threat on the board and if
black does bring the queen all the way
forward to the Central Square stopping
that white can make a retreating move
with the Knight hit that Queen on e4 and
force it back and get that Central Pawn
moving uh this can be big pressure for
black yeah if these two pawns land on e4
and D4 they control all the squares they
neutralize uh the vision of those black
minor pieces they really take away some
squares the knights aren't necessarily
on great circuits right now okay you can
plant a knight on a nice Outpost but
suddenly boom The Rook lands on the
seventh Rank and disaster for black uh
potentially
yeah suddenly big questions to answer
for for Asia I think a big question is
why he made his previous move uh the
position is one that is very complicated
so we don't want to be overly critical
but H6 just kind of a casual Pawn push
in a position that's getting very messy
a loud white the time to bring the Rook
to E1 and push this Pawn up in the
center kicking away Black's minor pieces
so I think that H6 was just a little bit
too slow in the position he probably
should have moved his Queen up out of
the pin and that way his Knights could
be a bit more free so I just think that
that last move from fridges one he'll
regret yeah you can't play Slow moves
you don't have that luxury in these
types of positions and maybe that's just
a bit of rust for Asia it feels like
he's not quite at his best yet in terms
of uh kind of the energetic play that
we're used to seeing from him but uh
will he find a justification for that
strange Pawn push this is the current
position after white removes The Rook uh
to E1 and big threat on the board he
needs to solve it he needs to find an
antidote and okay nine minutes full
version eight minutes for a Regice this
one still in the balance for now but uh
black the one under pressure
we do have some questions coming in on
Twitter with some viewers using the
hashtag chess Champs there is a question
for you actually right now Tanya and I
bet this is from a fan in India
wondering what chances you give origin
of winning the whole thing
well you know as commentators we're
supposed to be not buyers but I'm going
to admit that I was super happy to see
two Indians make it to this first
division of the first ever double
elimination bracket that we've got we
had six spots up for qualification and
gaucasian Arjun both made it to the top
amazing and in a great way in the
playoffs uh I think Arjun you know he's
had such a meteoric rise he was around
2500 and then over a period of a year he
gained about a hundred points went on to
play in the Champions Chester in a
brilliant way at the Tata steel chess
India rapid and Blitz who would have
thought that he would have won the
championship he won the rapid uh lost in
the playoff in the blitz finished second
so I think he's definitely someone to
watch out for now when you've got
players like Hikaru and Magnus and
Wesley playing you know it's not going
to be easy but in my heart I am rooting
for Arjun and gokish there I said it
you're very loud too very loud
definitely well Tanya you must be happy
to see the last movie the board because
the evaluation bars reacted in arjun's
favor wow we need to figure out why now
which is less clear maybe but it's
looking good for white David I
understand the more rookie we've been
screaming about this idea of E4 and
getting that Rook to C7 so alireza tries
to challenge that open Rook on the C5
but the one thing that stands out is now
the Knight on D7 is just super tender
if you're able to build up an attack on
that that would be bad news yeah this
would be terrible news if we can put
pressure on this D7 Knight looks
difficult at the moment I'm wondering
whether um you can for example trade off
one set of Rooks actually I was told
that especially in these imbalances
Rooks versus minor pieces you want to
have one of everything it's like ice
cream flavors once your opponent doesn't
have any Rooks anymore here black uh
doesn't have any Rooks suddenly you
become very tender on certain uh squares
and especially if the white Rook gets
into the game and now I'm wondering do
you push the pawn up maybe you switch
the bishop back onto this diagonal maybe
this would be a nasty threat for black
to deal with actually now I look at it
this looks devastating and okay he
doesn't go for this era guy see I was
going to say now the Knight can be
defended yes for example you can back it
up with another Knight but finally
overpower the knight in the center once
it moves white breaks through on the
diagonal you winner the second well
third Point sorry and uh this looks
crushing almost and uh Robert instead
he's gone for something else he's missed
this opportunity and played E4 is this
equally strong I think it's a case of
mutual oversight we've had so much focus
on the C file and the pin on the Knight
on D7 that looking at the F7 Square
being tender was kind of out of their
mind so I get why both players miss it
there's just so much else going on but a
missed opportunity there for Arden his
position still looks very good if you
can push your opponents in the center
you have two extra pawns you want to
make use of them you're limiting the
scope of your enemy's pieces but the
more your pawns move up the board uh one
of those Bishops might end up thriving
so it's a double-edged position and I
think Ali Reza now he all of a sudden
with a knight in enemy camp he can be
feeling a little bit better even if he
objectively is worse here yep he's
struggling but he does have this one
very active piece and uh yeah you want
to kick it out you want to get rid of it
as soon as possible thus uh Eric I see
comes over swings his Queen and drives
the Knight back he is pushing this piece
back if it has to retreat momentum white
yet again so still looking good for Eric
icy maybe not as good as it could have
been he could have won another Pawn to
add to this collection but uh still very
strong and ferricia is having to contort
himself play some odd looking moves now
pushing a pawn to G5 that's very
weakening very loose that type of move
it needed to happen it needed to be done
and he's Clinging On to active squares
for his pieces there is a bit of a
difference building up on the clock
aeroglyce certainly spending a lot
longer in this game than he did on the
previous attacking Masterpiece uh from
game one but uh if he speeds up he's
still doing very well Tanya still
cheering for him 100 now Arjun realizes
that he's he should be better in this
position as long as he keeps those minor
pieces that black has under control the
pawn structure in the center takes away
so many key squares that Bishop on B5
pinning down that Knight on D7 so he
knows the position's good but he can't
slow down he has to make sure that he
keeps up the pressure now Black's last
move the pawn pushed to G5 it controls
his own Knight on F4 but does give up
the F5 square and I was I was thinking
about this that land something on H4 I
was wondering if the Knight can go on H4
but Arjun comes up with another idea
David of trying to break that pawn chain
and I look at our valbar it doesn't love
the move but from a human perspective I
think it's very strong yeah suddenly
asking really difficult questions of
version right now how do you defend that
pawn that's just been attacked on G5 if
that porn ever gets dislodged then the
Black Knight Falls and
difficult suddenly it does feel like
you're being overwhelmed over kind of
stretched your defenses the black queen
is tied down she's looking in so many
different directions she needs to defend
her Knight her rook and she can't kind
of swing to the defense of her King
I'm struggling to find moves here as
black I've got to say I think he's gonna
have to slightest Queen one square over
to the starting Square either after The
Rook trade or in the current position
and that way you defend this Pawn on G5
uh tactics May favor the side with more
pieces on the board and black has two
minor pieces for a rook so the queen may
be overloaded but if you start some
trades perhaps it's blacks pieces that
go into the position and start creating
attacks and the white king is the one
that actually lacks shelter yep I want
to point out
that the players need to watch out for
after H4 we are looking at this line
with Rook takes he won the trade on C1
and David you're pointing out that white
picks it up with The Rook which is such
a natural move and black does have the
opportunity once you do that to actually
capture the pawn on e4 because look at
the geometry with that Knight on F4
targeting the E2 Square where it can
Fork the king and the Rook you can allow
the Knight on D7 to be hanging because
the bishop on V5 needs to defend the E2
square and I think the tactics just seem
to be working out and look at this Rook
C1 on the board and Arjun needs to be
careful now yeah this could happen this
variation you mentioned a night check
Landing it's four or five moves in the
future but the fact that Eric icy is
post means it's on his radar this is not
going to happen David yeah I think
you're right but we needed to show that
it's a it's kind of a potential slip up
here for aragaisy if he takes with the
Rook things will turn around in Black's
favor as you mentioned that Tanya Queen
takes Pawn would be extremely strong
picking off one of White's kind of Pride
prized possessions there in the center
but the fact he has stopped means he's
going to calculate and he's going to
realize he has to take with the queen
and now you definitely don't want to
take this Pawn with the bishop because
uh you walk into a pin on the e-file end
there we go you predicted it it does
take with the queen and still in the
balance but Black's Queen now getting
active at least creating some threats
Robert mentioned it a couple of moves
ago potentially the white king couldn't
come under Fire oh my goodness this is
one of those positions where the
evaluation bar does not tell the story
we see objectively white is better with
the best moves operative word being best
it's difficult to make great moves when
that Queen is sliding up to the G4
Square two squares in the diagonal
towards the white king and there's
checkmating threats immediately and it's
the only way to stop Checkmate is by
pushing that pawn in front of your king
you almost never want to push Pawns in
front of your king but it opens up
diagonals it creates weak squares and
Black's forced about to hop right in
this could be big trouble if our generic
IC does not show pinpoint accuracy yeah
and it's going to be difficult to show
that type of accuracy with only three
minutes on the clock minimal increment
coming on per move okay he takes a pawn
but this is really playing with fire
we've got to say the black queen is
poised she's ready to jump in I'm not
sure whether she will immediately but
that threat will stay on the cards for
the next few moves there's all sorts of
captures here the Black Knight can even
take a Pawn on G2 have to work out the
consequences there worse comes to worse
for farooja you just take this Pawn back
the white Pawn on G5 and you say okay
the tactics are still in the air I'll
make you think I'll make you calculate a
bit more the fact the evaluation bar
hasn't reacted means that maybe there's
no knockout blow for black and uh maybe
no tactics work right now but that's
what Ferris is going to spend his
remaining time on he's going to spend a
while trying to figure out whether he
can go for that white king immediately
this is such a brave decision by our
gender take on G5 I mean if I was white
I would see Knight takes cheat do with
the queen coming in with the check and I
wouldn't have the heart to go for it and
alireza brings up the queen first
attacking threatening a mid in one on
the board Arjun immediately blitzes out
G3 so he has calculated this very
important defense where yes black can
pick up the Knight on F3 but then white
goes on to win the Knight on F4
it's lucky that White's Queen is sitting
there uh watching from afar to defend
her King uh the White Queen would swoop
into defend just in time in this
variation so farusha can't go for this
he lands a check the king moves and now
the question is can he get to this white
king or not if he can't then there's a
bunch of problems you've got too many
pawns uh now you've given up too many
pawns to go for this attack also this
Knight is under Fire so farouza I'm
surprised he went for that queen move so
quickly he just recaptures on G5 can he
keeps the momentum flowing huge threat
Knight H3 back to F4 is the threat you
need the pawn on G5 because without that
pawn there the queen on C1 would capture
the Knight now it is defended the G3
Pawn is pinned to the white king that's
a huge threat so maybe at this point uh
White has to start backtracking and then
Knight on F3 it looks like it's on a
good square but maybe it has to drop
back to H2 kick that Queen out of there
keep it safe and sound but I'm looking
at this position and I feel like with
arjun's time in particular it's looking
really scary despite the fact that he is
object actually better I think you have
to balance the position with the clock
yeah there's all sorts of calculation to
do here either the black queen can move
you can maybe even snag a Pawn on e4 and
calculate a whole bunch of checks it's
getting chaotic let's Let The Players
try and figure out what's happening here
um I don't think we'll see in an
error-free game from this point because
it's so easy to go wrong I think at some
point someone's going to make a mistake
and and it's just about who makes the
last mistake as it gets even more
chaotic first I think Robert's right
Eric icy needs to take defensive
measures he needs to move that white
knight before it's too late can Arjun
allow himself more than a minute the
thinking pause now some positions you
can survive on a minute it doesn't feel
like this is one of them oh wow and he
brought the notebook and look at how
quickly other Scoops up the pawn with
check against that white king So if you
decide to push your Pawn up to F3 okay
guys I think we're gonna see another
Sacrifice from Ali razor he's gonna keep
giving away pieces exposing the white
king yeah we have to show this because
this would end in some cool little
tactics cool night jumps this would be
the most natural move for white blocking
a check looks like you're forking two
pieces here attacking the bishop
attacking the queen but Bishop takes
Pawn would be pretty much obligatory
here and after a recapture the Black
Knight jumps back with a nasty check and
uh when the king moves could we see a
little dance between the knight and king
maybe we'll see another Knight check the
white king would have to jump out into
the open if it wants to avoid a draw
here uh repetition may be uh the most
logical finish instead Eric icy doesn't
want just a draw he doesn't want that to
repeat he gave up his Rook for the
bishop in the center and now he's
captured this Black Knight on the edge
of the board so it's now a completely
different assortment of material it's
one point in White's favor but his King
is on the edge of the board precarious
stuff oh my goodness white desperately
wants to trade off the Queens because if
we actually do a quick material count a
weight has Five Pawns black only has
force of the Queens just disappear white
has extra material the presence of
opposite colored Bishops that's
important to store in your backpack and
in your memory bank because that means
with the queen trade it's likely the
resulting Position will be a a game
where the point of split a draw looks
the likeliest outcome but the Queens are
still on the white king is out on in the
open on H3 that could be really
dangerous especially with the clock
ticking down yep on every guy see side
here however pieces are coming off the
board so it will be slightly easier to
navigate with no time on the clock he's
attacking this Knight he's attacking
this pawn and I think for now there's
not enough attackers around the white
king to take advantage of its uh
positioning so there's uh almost no time
to breathe in this game I'm so impressed
that farrugia has found his way through
these complications still with four and
a half minutes on his clock because
there were so many options so many
twists and turns uh just in that last
tactical sequence but we've emerged with
this position and yeah Eric Garcia would
love an endgame he's not going to be
given one however farisha is going to
keep going for that white king what do
you think will be the results right now
in this game will we see a winner will
it be a draw what do you think
is so tough to answer because this
position is literally playing for all
results everything is possible and it
looks like yes uh draw might be a likely
outcome but the path to that draw is
going to be super risky Anything Can
Happen one of the ideas that comes to
mind for alireza is to give a check on
F5 you were mentioning the pawn on G5 is
attacked the Knight on D7 is attacked a
check on F5 would defend and guard both
these undefended pieces but alireza
doesn't care about defense he wants to
pick up that Central Pawn he goes for it
but in return has to give up this very
key Pawn I said draw is a likely result
cut that out I think that despite the
material deficit that Alvarez is playing
for a win he's saying we have Bishops
opposite colors in the end game that
made me in a draw but when you're
attacking I mean you can't actually
Parry off my Bishop it's on the dark
squares years on the light squares then
Knight on C5 trying to hop into the E4
square right next to the queen just
going towards the enemy King this could
be difficult for Arjuna geisi remember
there's only a three second increment
and he is down towards his final minimum
o'clock oh yeah yeah so easy to go wrong
here he brings his Knight forward that's
a defensive maneuver as well as an
attacking idea uh he's just guarding
that white F2 pawn and uh also hinting
that he might jump forward with some
nasty checks towards the black king
suddenly farrugia has to find an equally
multi-purpose move perhaps he needs to
go for that white king but he also needs
to keep watchful eye over his King yeah
opposite color Bishops I've always found
those the most difficult positions to
evaluate uh to handle because it's never
clear who's attacking who's on the
defensive and I think both sides are
playing for the win here they would both
uh want to push this one uh even further
and okay first in an attack against the
White Queen
Black Knight sitting on a really nice
Square I've got to say and I'm just
trying to look for safe squares for her
for her majesty here the White Queen
does find one on F5 but uh okay Black's
Queen if she could somehow land herself
behind the white king Imagine The Black
Queen on the bottom right hand corner of
the board on H1 that would be
devastating threats there so uh what is
uh farouza gonna go for he could also be
greedy here and take time out to grab
that white Pawn on B2 but it doesn't
feel too relevant right now so I would
be slightly surprised to see that one
and it will allowed that Bishop which
has been sitting on B5 forever before it
was pinning at night now it's doing
nothing except for staring in thin air
if that Bishop can slide back onto a new
diagonal staring towards the black king
right that Bishop gets the C4 you're
hitting the Knight and the F7 Pawn
behind it that could be really
problematic for alireza farusia so he
should not look at the clock and think
I'm gonna go flag origin era guys this
is one of the best bullet chess players
in the world I mentioned earlier he won
the junior speed chess championship by
taking out nihal sarin everybody should
know nihal Saran for being the runner-up
in the global Championship so you you
don't want to just look at the clock he
needs to play the board here and he has
brought his Queen D1 looking at David's
plan of going over to the H1 square but
it seems like it was a mistake
whoa yeah what is happening here maybe
white can just ignore this I thought it
was a killer threat but White's Knight
is just about uh able to jump back and
defend so right now maybe there's a
killer move and wow look at what era
guys he's done uh I wasn't gonna I
wasn't 100 sure about suggesting this
one but Eric I was very confident here
he lands his Bishop on this diagonal
that Robert was mentioning and what
verusia might have missed is that any
check from behind looks like Checkmate
but white tonight can just jump back and
defend suddenly the black queen is
offside she's in no man's land she
doesn't want to be on this side of the
board she's needed as a Defender and
huge threats against the black King
instead
wow maybe sorry uh go on Tanya finish
your furniture I was gonna say mate was
just a bit of a bluff life for Russia
and now he's regretting it yeah we saw
that little head shake by farouja there
I think he completely missed the fact
that Queen H1 is not a Checkmate and
after the Knight comes back to H2 you
realize that Knights are not only great
attackers but also really good Defenders
you see how it controls all the squares
around the king there are no checks on
the board Bishop E6 is a massive threat
yes you can fall back with your queen to
C6 now to try and defend that Knight on
E6 but now black has run out of fire
completely no threats against White's
King uh White simply makes a move like
B3 gods that Bishop on C4 and White's
dominating yeah well it's dominating the
Knight can come back to a more active
Square later black is completely Frozen
uh once you have to go on the defensive
that will only spell bad news and you
are pawned down to boots so not a great
turn in this game for far Asia he's
looking really downcast you see him on
the camera head in hands now uh his last
move was a bit of a complacent one
perhaps for sure because if you're going
to be a pawn down in some positions you
want the opposite colored Bishops an
added bonus of having this bishop on C4
is that some moment the right moment
we'll see Arjun take that Knight on E6
and enter a position with Knight versus
Bishop that extra Pawn will tell the
story so I'll raise it he's on the
defensive he's on his back foot he
brings his Quint all the way back to C6
A3 David your suggestion is great simple
strong defending everything yep you
could make an argument maybe for taking
that black knight right now but uh I
don't think there's any Rush that there
we go B3 on the board the most natural
move that black knight is not going
anywhere it's an easy target for White's
Bishop White's Bishop is now far far
superior to its counterpart we were
talking about the opposite color Bishops
the color complexes there's so many
targets for that white Bishop there's no
targets for the black Bishop it's
hitting thinner and uh yeah it's turning
in White's favor and white is still an
extra Pawn up you've got that material
advantage you're out of danger with your
own King the Knight jumping back into
the attack you might dissolve the
problem of the opposite color Bishops
these endings are always known to be a
bit joyous but that might not be the
case once the bishop and the Knights are
traded off this looks like Arjun could
be headed towards a second Victory but
of course alireza is going to make that
super hard and he moves the night away
but look at the clocks both players are
on the 32nd Mark that is dangerous
territory look at this play by origin
centralizing the bishop no more Queen
H1s for you he's going to be able to
bring his Knight back into the game next
and if that Knight hops forward into the
enemy territory there could be Checkmate
threats yeah we'll see that white knight
get back into the action leap back there
and also this pattern between the white
bishop and the Black Knight last year
Simon Williams the ginger GM he called
it the night stable the Knight is locked
at home can never move without being
captured by that white Bishop it's Total
Domination and wow Eric I see he just
takes a time out to keep his Kings safe
that white king now super safe in its
Palace there surrounded by pawns Black's
King has fewer Defenders around it this
one is certainly heading towards a white
wind right now he just needs to get his
Knight maybe to a more active square but
uh for Asia clinging on for dear life
and uh yeah how are you guys at bullet
chess this is under 20 seconds for both
players it's getting nerve-wracking now
but look at Arjuna he doesn't look
nervous at all and this is what I've
always admired about him that in the
face of extreme time pressure just the
best in him comes out he's still we can
see with the valbar making the best
moves keeping his pieces centralized
keeps everything protected this is some
great advice by the way uh that whenever
you're low on the clock just make sure
that everything's protected the bishop
on C4 is guarded by the B3 Pawn the
Queen's guarded by the king the knights
defended everything under control whoa
everything under control but suddenly
the position has changed there were two
or three very very quick moves there and
suddenly for Russia has grabbed a pawn
that white Pawn on F2 was captured by
the black Bishop the White Queen is
overloaded having to defend her own
Bishop in the center couldn't take that
black Bishop Now Pawn is dropping into
black king it's total chaos despite the
reduced material and Black's King is on
the run but then Knight on d8 do not
take it with the Knight F7 that makes a
very bad piece you'd much I thought it
was night back to E5 with check and say
that Knight is dominated on the back row
it said he brings a queen in with check
I feel like the black king is Slithering
away and that gives alireza increased
chances to survive yeah and it feels
like Eric I see the nerves are kicking
in he's giving a few checks to gain time
on the incremental 28 now yeah he's
attacked the diagonal this check could
be blocked by Black's Bishop the black
Bishop slid back to block and still a
dance between the white king uh White
Queen and the black king leaning back
though and it's over he won peace he won
a piece the black king now cannot take
that white knight because then you lose
your bishop and Eric I see we almost
missed it there but spun it in his favor
and there's no check on the white king
the black king overloaded and this is
just game over what a finish and that we
have a result we've got two zero by
origin he takes a massive lead wow RJ
and Eric I see what a player he goes up
by two points and that means otherwise
he's gonna be in a must-win situation in
game three to have a chance of winning
the match what a day he's having Arjun
eragaisy winning game two I did see
Magnus Carlsen he did as well win game
number two going up two points in his
match an AC car Nakamura about to do the
same and this is not the position from
this game this is the position from game
one of the day so uh hopefully we can
get an update of Refresh on that board
it looks like okay Hikaru leaning back
he did just take the win and uh
hopefully we'll get a chance to see the
final position there but I can confirm
kakesh has just resigned in that game it
was a similar final position where
Hikaru nakumar won an end game so the
game lasted quite a while but two games
in a row it's Al Hikaru wow so we have
three players now up by two points and
their matches some incredible chests
going on today in the air things
monsters we did follow game two with our
generic IC and Ali rest of Russia can
you give us the highlights David how is
Arjun able to win that game yeah I just
want to show a few moments because it
went so quickly at the end it was fast
it was Furious and it all started around
here farusha actually spotted a really
cunning tactic as black we knew he was a
pawn down we knew the black king was in
some danger but he spotted he could grab
this F2 Pawn uh this white F2 Pawn
because the White Queen cannot step back
and capture
suddenly the white Bishop would
disappear everything would be equal and
ferrugia would save the game instead
Eric he went on the counter attack he
took a port near the black king the what
black Bishop retreated and we were
saying there were a bunch of checks here
very tempting checks but don't trade off
pieces don't trade the knights that
would lead perhaps towards a draw and uh
with a bunch of clever checks continuing
to chase the black king he found this
maneuver checking the King on the
diagonal maybe ferris's mistake was to
not go this way I'm surprised he didn't
run towards safety on this side of the
board instead he stepped towards the
center and after a few more checks we
see the killer blow Queen check on F5
hitting the king hitting the bishop and
when the king defended its Bishop
suddenly Knight takes Knight no
salvation anymore black has zero checks
no way to counter attack and if the
black king takes the White Knight the
bishop Falls game over Eric I see two
nil up
[Music]
this whole concept of just bulldozing
the black king jumping in there with the
queen and making sure the Rook comes in
with a ladder mate is everything this
chapter is about everything this chapter
is about
the point is I don't want you to get a
move that's not in the course and go I
don't know what to do
92 of games get to this position from
this position white is winning about 60
70 of the time and I think if you learn
these lines that very easily could be 75
or 80 for you
[Music]
is joining me in the studio to talk
about this new exciting season of the
Champions chess store but if you're not
yet a subscriber on Twitch we're going
to send you to a twitch break now
[Music]
I still call you tour director Arnold
but you actually have a new title what
is it very long it's hard to say but we
can I'm here now as the head of
Championship production head of
Champions chess tour production it is
the first day of the air things Masters
the event the first day of the 2023
season how are you doing are you excited
I'm so excited so
amazing to finally be on the road again
with this new exciting format in this
new environment that we're part of now
so this is really cool yeah and there's
so much new stuff to the Champions chess
tour what is the
big idea behind the whole new format the
idea is to take the best from both
worlds from the play Magnus world and at
chess.com World chess.com who has this
amazing reach play Magnus who has been
working a lot of innovation on how to
distribute chess and see how we can
really take the best from both worlds
and make this the most exciting tour for
everyone to follow yeah what would you
say is the biggest difference from the
two first season to the 2023 season
first of all that we have all the big
names being able to participate in this
we have an amazing prize fund we have an
amazing reach and also the fact that we
are going from invited players now to a
full open system of qualifiers which
means that everybody who really has it
in them to be a part of the tour can in
theory qualify and the goal though it
must still be the same to grow chests to
a wider audience grow the game make just
more interesting accessible and viewable
for wider Audits and now with the
amazing boom that just has Now is really
the time also for us to work on this to
create a concept together both
consecrated tour that is incredibly
exciting both for those who love chess
already but also for all those new fans
getting new grass through the game yeah
and you've been a part of this from the
very start the actually from the very
start when it was called the Magnus
Carlsen limitation Invitational I think
yeah a couple years ago uh coveted hit
the Champions chess tour was born and
now it's growing even bigger even better
what is it like to be a part of it it's
it's it's amazing you have to pinch your
arm and you have to take it one step
back and actually think about what we
all are a part of right now the
incredible boom that's happening in the
interest of Jess and that it just keeps
on growing and what we all the
opportunities that we have ahead of us
now is is really really amazing yeah and
we know these first days always hectic
have you been able to follow any of the
chess
a little bit what do you think about the
level the action the players are
bringing so far it's uh it's really cool
to see you it's uh it's it's so many new
elements now in the first day of a
broadcast that there's a lot of things
to to put together to make sure
everything fits but uh what I've been
able to watch so far has been really
amazing
and something else that is new is uh the
panel here in the Oslo studio with Tanya
and Robert now joining uh David and
myself in the studio and Ivanka and when
everyone when anyone new comes to Norway
we have to give them a cold welcome
come on Tanya come on in
what's the worst thing that can happen
to someone nothing you have a steal put
this in there whip up a little bit here
and close it and now we are contacted
oh come on we'll be fine
[Music]
welcome to Apple the whole capital of
the world's best chess player Magnus
Carlson uh I feel like Bambi on ice but
we've got no excuse we're going to win
team England team England versus team
global we're gonna challenge you guys in
a cross-country relay oh oh my God
[Applause]
not so easy to I Will Survive
you can do this
coming home Tony you got this unlike the
Terminator I'm coming up oh my God I got
this help
[Music]
foreign
so we're done with the skiing Robert and
Tanya did take the win but now we're
back in our natural habitat at the good
night chess club and Ivanka and I we
have a chance for Revenge
just Castle from safety
[Music]
so sneaky
oh my gosh what is that
[Music]
all right we got this we got this we got
this
how
okay nice move
Under Pressure yes
[Music]
it's been good
good night
if we'd gone the other way
I'm over here still yeah it's okay Queen
C6 is so true
foreign
for dressing up our experts in their new
very uh cool Four Seasons collection so
you were comfortable clothing wise how
did you feel on those keys Tanya
petrified
this Giza was pretty Apparent from the
video but
beating fast
ing fastly
we were excellent
I know I started like an absolute
disaster on those skis
and you got the hang of it I'm very
impressed and David you are I've said to
you so many times the most competitive
person I know you were very upset after
losing that battle I don't want to talk
about it it was a fix it
but uh it was a lot of fun and congrats
to these two it's all my fault though
Ivanka was awesome uh I just let us down
in both the skiing and the chest yeah
good start for team global in the Oslo
Studio nice
all right and it's a good start
especially for three players in the air
things monsters these are the results
after two games so far Magnus Carlsen is
up by two points that means I like say
Serana he has to win game three to take
it to a game four situation is the same
for you cash in a must win situation in
game three Hikaru Nakamura is up by two
points and so is Arjun Eric icy winning
two games in a row against alireza
Russia Wesley so and Ralph Mama though
they have played two roles and they are
tied so far so Robert who's impressed
you the most so far today it has to be
our generic I see because Magnus Carlson
hikar Nakamura they're always the
favorite unless they're playing each
other in which case the toss-up but for
our generic I see he's been unbelievable
he's finding the tactics even when he's
down on time he's still playing the best
moves and he earned himself those two
wins definitely
we're gonna follow the next game between
Hikaru and Nakamura and yukash with
yukash being in a must win situation
Hikaru on fire today so what is it about
for the 16 year old Indian right now
Tanya
he had a phenomenal run at the
qualifiers in the Swiss plane he
finished right at the top and then very
strategic bold decision of playing
against Vladimir kramnik in the playoff
and won that 2-0 and then what he gets
as a prize is a first round matchup
against Hikaru Nakamura an absolute
based a monster in this format and
undoubtedly Hikaru is a big favorite and
he's showing us why uh cookies has to
win on demand he has to give this next
game everything and more it's a tough
task ahead of him yeah must win
situation for three players we couldn't
have asked for a more dramatic start to
the Champions chess tour 2023 and here
we go game three you cash with the white
pieces uh we should have asked for
another prediction from Ukiah you would
have got it right again and nothing
default and uh no Queen's Gambit here
and Nakamura which opening will he
choose of course he plays Everything
Under the Sun Nakamura he tends to go
towards the Queen's gamber declined when
he's in doubt when he just wants a solid
position
it's not just about getting out of the
opening it's about getting out of the
opening with a bunch of pieces left with
a very tense position I do feel that the
only way to beat Nakamura for get cash
now will be to attack him somehow the
end game has proven to be uh nakamura's
forte in this matchup today at least and
it's another London system though so uh
do we Boo this one or do we think it's a
great match strategy for gokish well you
mentioned he needs to keep all the
pieces on the water from that approach I
think it makes a lot of sense you're
hoping for the long game here uh Hikaru
needs just a draw to wrap up this match
so it's definitely a tough task ahead of
GK she's going to throw everything he's
got he starts slow one of the things
that players often end up doing in a
must-win situation is play these rash
openings and they don't end well so I
like that gauquacious at least kept calm
and chosen this line which kind of gives
him the opportunity to get a middle game
to just play for a normal game and
hopefully not get into an end game like
you're mentioning yeah he's gonna keep
all the pieces on the board this is uh
rare sideline of the London system where
white has had to commit a move to
playing them to playing Rook B1 just
defending that B Pawn Black's Queen
coming out early that comes with some
risk involved but at least white does
get the time to set up this triangle of
Pawns supporting the London Bishop but
wow Nakamura trading off the light Squad
Bishops looks like a French defense gone
right for black very right uh the bad
piece for black and French is that light
Square Bishop up but I know Simon
Williams Ginger GM he always loves these
lines of the bishop sliding out to D7
then to B5 offering a trade and that
means that the pawn structure is very
solid for black F7 e6d5 great foundation
in the center uh for uh Hikaru Here and
Now The Bishop's out of the way he can
then develop his Knight and keep
everything under control yep it looks
really nice as a bit of a bonus here if
the bishops get traded off black does
prevent the white king from castleing
the queen uses her vision there to
control one of the squares the king
would want to Castle through and of
course you can't Castle through check
you can try and kick the queen away for
example with a move like A4 but the
black queen for example could keep uh
itself on this diagonal and I'm
struggling to find ways now to keep the
pieces on the board I mentioned that
kokesh ideally wants to keep the tension
he's clearly been surprised in this
opening he's Burnt Over a minute already
it's only move seven and uh no clear way
to keep the Bishops on apart from this
one wow Pawn to C4 moving the pawn for a
second time in the last two moves he's
literally just pushed that pawn but he
moves it again and at the cost of time
at least he'll keep some tension and I'm
not sure now whether he'll take back
with his Knight or his Bishop either way
at least he will ask Nakamura some
questions I do fear for kakash if
Nakamura is in home preparation however
it does feel like the type of position
where if you've done your homework you
will be able to just Hoover off a bunch
of pieces and we see those pieces
disappearing uh okay a queen check a
double attack but luckily white can
slide the Knight back to defend and a
bunch more exchanges are happening what
has Nakamura just reacted to he's uh
talking to himself just asking himself
the question what's happened he did just
take a pawn is this a mistake maybe he
forgot his preparation looks very
natural to me Robert yeah it looks like
a completely normal move so it could be
a Hikaru gesticulating just uh kind of
putting on appearances for the show but
at the same time maybe there is
something he didn't like because
sometimes when you release the tension
too early that gives the opponent some
extra opportunities of some freedom for
the pieces I think Black Edition looks
great white has an isolated Pawn so this
Pawn on D4 cannot be defended by another
Pawn the good news inherents are having
in iqp isolated Queen Pawn is the
adjacent files are open so Rook can
eventually size the e-file a rook to the
C file that's great but the Pawn's a
perennial Target black has no risk in
the foundation of his position so I
think Hikaru is in everything you could
ask for from play with having the black
pieces yep and here white has Castle was
saying okay you can take my Pawn on D4
but it will come at the cost of time and
Nakamura meanwhile brings his Rook
across again not necessarily to even win
this Pawn but to control its advance and
let's go back to the players this one
will result in a very tense middle game
white has that a ton of weakness so
needs to compensate it uh compensate for
it with active play I mean while go cash
trying to kick the black queen out of
his Camp saying get out of here you've
done uh enough you've caused enough
nuisance so far and uh maybe Nakamura
could grab this Pawn in the center next
move if he's feeling greedy remember a
draw suits him though so uh plenty of
solid moves solid Alternatives at his
disposal as well okay
three players are in must win situations
in this round of games go cash is one of
them can we see that in the way he has
started this game that he's just going
all out
yeah I would say yes he's going for the
London system he's trying to keep peace
on the board but Nakamura hasn't really
allowed him to there's been a trade of
two sets of Pawns one set of minor
piecesh I think he goes all out in every
game Kaya that's uh that's the thing
about him it's hard to tell when he's
playing solid I don't think I've ever
seen a cash play solid uh he's always
very ambitious and that's why he's
already reached the upper echelons of uh
World Chess or at such a such a young
age and there is a question there what
do you guys think about kukesha's
opening choices Robert well I think that
he's playing what he knows and he needs
to take risks somewhere the problem is
in certain lines that have risk is if
somebody has studied it in which case in
this case a card certainly has figured
out this opening you can combat it in
some forcing ways and that's the last
thing you want in a must win game is to
have a forcing variation that your
opponent knows so at least in the
current position we have white with the
bishop pair only white has a light
Square Bishop whereas black has the two
knights so there is something to play
for this game isn't going to immediately
conclude so I think that I like his
choice here in game three the earlier
games I didn't look into enough depth
but I feel like Hikaru is Hikaru at the
end of the day yeah
and uh Tanya earlier the fans were
asking about Eric icy is the the same
level of support in India for good cash
oh
Loveless sport for the Indian youngsters
and kukesh has so far really shown his
class in classical play we had his
breakout performance during the Olympic
wow what a phenomenal tournament that
was but after that he had a couple of
disappointing results uh even the Tata
steel was his debut but it was a
lukewarm performance at least by the
standards that he sets for himself a
huge learning experience we haven't seen
vocation as much in Rapid and Blitz we
haven't seen him that much in speed
chess which is what made it even more
impressive his run in the qualifiers so
playing against Hikaru here I think this
is a lot to do with experience we were
talking about opening choices I like
that he's gone for the initiative he
doesn't mind giving up that D4 Pawn for
keeping black skin in the center we see
a developing move there by Hikaru not
getting greedy in the center he had no
time to do that allowing checks on the
B5 Square G3 a nice solid move
eventually what white wants to do is
start pushing the beep on off the board
you want to go B4 you want to get B5 Now
The Rook is on C1 it's x-raying that
Queen on season seven so as far as
opening choices are concerned I think in
a win-on-demand game gokish has done it
right so far yeah it's hard to get a big
advantage against the top guys in the
world from the opening but he's got all
the pieces still on the board uh most of
the piece is still on the board and
still a lot to play for meanwhile how
are you guys feeling because we can see
the air quality in the studio here
we should be feeling good we should lots
of green there I'm feeling great and
lots of green next to me because Tanya
she wore the good color today and I feel
like you know you can't win them all in
India right now two players in the top
division but you should be pretty happy
Argent era garci he is taking down at
least in the first two games alireza
fuja and gukesh has a chance here in
game three even though nakamura's
position is very solid and this is why
you're glad that
I mean there's so there are so many
Indian fans who
fans here a tough start in this match it
doesn't mean the end of the road for him
he still has one more shot at the
tournament
yeah so he's guaranteed to be here
tomorrow no matter what definitely and
meanwhile gakesh is throwing those pawns
forward before it's too late he throws
his Pawn forward to before
I messed up that pun
okay he's uh played B4 and he's trying
to push even further forward to dislodge
those black knights and uh yeah for
Nakamura you're Rock Solid you're
controlling the square in front of the
isolated Pawn Black's Knight on the D5
Square looks fantastic you never really
want to trade that off if you're good
cash either because it will come at the
cost of your beautiful Bishop pair but
uh the question for Nakamura is whether
you just stay solid curl up into a ball
cover all your squares which he's doing
right now the black queen also very
passive
but uh yeah what next and I think that's
the question for both players perhaps
Jessica cash just continue advancing his
pawns maybe on both flanks on both sides
of the board to try and to create some
weaknesses use maybe some pawns as a
battering ram or do both players just
sit and maintain the status quo it's a
very tense position open to
interpretation in terms of plans and uh
I'm still slightly biased because I love
playing against isolated ones but uh
yeah good cash Bishop pair nice pieces
perfectly placed pieces it's just about
uh yeah the next step
yeah and the drawer is not enough for
him he has to win this game
it's never easy against Nakamura gotta
say okay sorry go ahead Tanya and that's
the biggest problem that you know he's
done everything right in this position
all the pieces are playing but what is
the next move how do you improve an
already very improved position here the
advantage that white does have in return
for that isolated Queen spawn is the
double Bishop bear but how good is that
with that Bishop on E3 just playing such
a big defensive role and guy as you
mentioned a draw is not enough at some
point you have to start taking risks and
here gokish is showing what his
intentions are he wants to try and set
up a battery along the b187 diagonal he
is trying to Target that eight seven
weaknesses weakness ideas of H4 Knight
G5 really hitting that soft spot on H7
come to mind as well so dukesh now
trying to build that uneven playground
in the middle game yeah and we saw it
work really effectively for Magnus
Carlson in game one of the day going for
that H7 point and it happens in a bunch
of different openings that pattern uh is
very very important to remember if black
ever does try and blunt the effect of
this bishop then I think the second plan
you mentioned uh Tanya that will come on
the board very very shortly I don't
think and kokesh will hesitate from
throwing this Pawn up the board you can
often just step forward with the white
king as well and slide The Rook behind
to propel it even further
um so still some ideas
um I do expect Hikaru here to rotate his
Knights as he likes to say on his Stream
So maybe drop this Knight back and try
and bring it to a more active Square
maybe for example then he could start
trying to trade off some pieces trade
off some Rooks black is still uh yeah
defending everything covering everything
but good cash is hinting at an attack
making Hikaru pause and then Bishop on
E3 isn't really doing all that much so
there's no rush for a car to take that
Bishop on the E3 Square because as soon
as you do white captures towards the
center with the pawn on F2 and once that
happened look at the quality of the
Bishops we keep talking about opposite
colored Bishops the bishop on D3 staring
all the way across towards the black
king but also can move one square
forward to put pressure on the black
queen side whereas the bishop on F6
staring into a brick wall a defended
Pawn on D4 so that I don't think would
be the best transition for Nakamura yeah
definitely something not to rush with
um the knights if we compare the pieces
that left the boat the knights uh just
one move earlier is far superior oh wow
this piece and just as we say that
commentators curse Robert wow he plays
the move we were just saying wouldn't be
a good idea and uh wow he's just happy
to uh fiancato now he's going to drop
his Bishop back and say that this is a
nice solid piece but you're right it
does stare against this kind of statue
of Pawns this Granite statue on D4
what a weird decision I've got to say
from Nakamura that must be influenced
surely by the fact he's got drawds in
this game yeah if he finds a concrete
solution he's gonna go for it so it's
something you strategically don't want
to do but maybe he has it all mapped out
and who would be surprised if icaro has
seen it through to the Finish Line takes
takes takes takes takes and maybe he has
the result in the bag yeah at some point
he will try and prepare a pawn break to
open diagonals for his Bishop meanwhile
Robert again seeing deep into the future
some pressure now along this diagonal
met by a night Retreat still very tense
but uh now I think despite what the
evaluation Bar says I would slightly
prefer white chances White's possession
at least easier to play perhaps in the
near future
it's a dramatic set of games right now
because we know he has to win so does
alireza farusha but I see the bar is
completely black it's actually Arjun
aragaisy winning another one
yes I'm just looking over at that board
and it looks like ferocious taking some
huge risks in the opening it's already
moved 15 there White's King is stuck in
the center hasn't castled he's barely
developed any pieces and Eric icy
looking in top form right now and then
Magnus Carlsen he as well with a draw or
win in game three will take the match
and the bar is saying he is winning is
that uh the full story yeah still some
work to do there it's level material but
uh strategic domination for Magnus
Carlsen he's fully in control of that
one and he just needs a draw remember so
uh Magnus he's gonna get that one he's
gonna guide it home and you guys
remember that you are in full control of
uh decisions in the studio if you feel
we need to jump to another game then you
call out I was going to say that before
white decided to go G4 G5 advancing the
pawn in front of his own King and this
is getting pretty hot on the board as it
is uh and gokish of course has to win on
demand to keep the match going and he's
doing everything he can to get a game I
like this move Queen to B5 it is towards
the queen side but what you want to do
is get further into your opponent's gang
account he's eyeing that D7 Square from
where he can hit the Knight on E7 he can
hit the rook and C8 the B7 Pawn is soft
uh so gokish here really creating his
chances yeah he's going for it this is
what he needs to do he needs to create
some imbalance that's already the
opposite color Bishops which doesn't
necessarily help long-term winning
chances so he has to create direct
threats I like it Tanya
um I'm not sure I go for it it's white G
Pawn push but in must win situations uh
yeah you've got to try something at
least there's an imbalance right all of
a sudden we have a situation where white
is going forward that could come at the
cost of overextension and then maybe
it's the white king that will find
itself in trouble but if the king
doesn't get checkmated or there's no
attack then I like the mobility of
White's pieces the bishop on G7 is
completely blunted by White's pawns so
some trades will be necessary from black
I think that black does have a good
position very strong Foundation there
I've been saying all game but I do like
it from the principle that a draw is
equivalent to a loss Google has to go
for it yep he has to go for it to
Nakamura for the first real time in the
game he's in the tank he's trying to
figure out how to
kind of neutralize the pressure here
I would just maybe move the pawn that's
under attack I don't see too many active
choices for black right now and still
solid very passive especially the black
minor pieces but nakamurae I think
solidity is the key word right now for
his position I'm also looking up at the
other games a bit distracted here
because it does look like Eric is found
a really powerful move in his game he's
uh gonna take that one home to Victory
soon that's uh Nakamura here making some
faces not entirely happy it feels like
with his position but he knows uh he's
still done nothing wrong so he shouldn't
be punished yet by kokesh's really
ambitious play and we know we shouldn't
believe the Expressions that Hikaru
gives a hundred percent they can be
super deceptive he needs just a draw so
of course there's a lot of margin here
for Hikaru but gukesh creating his
chances I'm also keeping an eye out on
the Arctic board whatever move barge and
David and we can perhaps jump to that
game because it's a big moment okay all
right
we're going to do that then Arjun Eric
icy has been crushing it today winning
the first two games against one of uh
the very best teenagers in the world
alireza farouza but the bar is saying he
is winning another one Arjun Eric I see
so we're gonna head over to that game
is that wind getting very close for him
yeah it is because uh for Alexandra he
needed to take a lot of risks and that
hibernation we've been talking about
where he where has he been nobody has
seen him in tournaments not even online
that can hurt you you need practice he
may be this higher rated player he may
even be the stronger player but with the
recent string of events that our generic
geiste has played in whether it be the
world rapid and World Blitz
championships then in tots of Steel he's
been working on his game honing his
craft and it's showing in this match
yeah he's looking really sharp aragaisy
and it was just a one move blunder we
should mention from farrugia in this
game but he has been taking risks and
necessary risks so it's not just about
this game which he most likely will lose
but the first two games of the day
didn't look like he was himself getting
out calculated by his uh his
contemporary there both 19 years old of
course will see that Clash for years to
come and we'll see them battle it out
for 10 20 years hopefully um these two
at the top of world chest but we're
waiting for that game to appear on our
boards I don't think farrugia has moved
in the last five minutes because he's
been so stunned by a strong reply by
Eric icy and we're jumping over here we
go it's a must-winning situation for
alireza Russia but you said it David
he's stunned he's stunt and look at his
pose for Asia right now he's only got
four minutes left he's been thinking for
so long Black's Queen jumping into the
center was the last move on the board
and while farouza tries to understand
how to survive here how to cope with the
ruins of his position let's go back and
show the last couple of moves because
every guy sees his last move this queen
jump was really spectacular and really
strong and it all started around here it
looked like Frugal played a very natural
move attacking the Black Knight did the
Knight have to drop back I Regice he
said no counter-attacking is another
option he attacked this white knight in
the center and farrugia here the big
mistake was not to start trading off
pieces instead he put his Knight on the
rim remember this was a mistake that
Serana played in the first game against
Magnus Carlson putting the Knight on the
side of the board there has to be a
concrete reason you do lose control over
the center yes the bishop is opened up
sorry to defend this Knight but you lose
control over the all-important D4 square
and queen to D4 Landing the queen
offering a trade here it's crushing I
after Queen takes Queen for example
black I don't know whether you take the
queen or you flick in a night check but
black can choose either it feels like
and when the king moves we just
recapture the queen and two many threats
this Rook is under Fire this Pawn is
under Fire And if you take a time out to
move the Rook black does get a bunch of
Pawns on this queen side there's
actually three or four very tempting
options I'm not sure which to choose
from you could take this Pawn uh you can
take this pawn and either way you will
eventually win an end game and let's
remember that all origin era Galaxy
needs of the black pieces is a draw but
that would be a winning position with no
chances for white so that is likely
we're gonna see something like that we
saw a queen trade on the board and I
like Knight C2 check such a good
intermetal you don't just have to
recapture on the D4 Square maybe it's
better for your knight on B4 to land
where the queen is and we just saw
Knight C2 check played our generic guys
he's doing everything right in this
match yeah and uh just to follow this
variation Knight takes Queen is about to
happen Bishop takes bishop and it does
look like white is creating a double
attack here but black can solve this in
a bunch of ways I think you can even
capture at this point attacking the
white rook and this one does get a bit
complicated I think ferocious banking
all of his hopes on this uh you can
attack this Black Knight but in a
position such as this one defending the
Knight Bishop takes Rook look at this
the white Rook is almost powerless in
the corner look at the strength of the
two black knights combined with their
protectors the two pawns black is
actually temporarily a whole Rook down
but you will gain back at least a piece
with interest and those two knights are
worth so much more this whole match by
archon has been his own version of
playing the Queen's Gambit his play with
the queen has been so strong in the
first round against Ali Reza he
sacrificed an entire Queen threatening a
Checkmate in the second round we saw
this amazing Queen dance where he
eventually won a piece and queen D4 in
this game what a star move and I think
it all comes down to the geometry that
he's been seeing with the tactics and
that's not an easy thing to do when
you're playing against the player like
Ali Reza who himself is so strong when
it comes to Tactical play but arjun's
just been on top of things from round
one in this one and how quick has he
been he's still got nine minutes on the
clock he sacrificed the whole Rook when
he only needs a draw he's taking huge
risks but he's seeing the board so
quickly so well right now and yeah fair
play he's going to take the win and they
often say when all you need is a draw
the best thing to do is play your normal
chats play you're not playing for a win
necessarily but as soon as you start
getting overly solid you might get a bit
passive not thinking about all your
options that's no longer chest that's
just subjective thinking so Arjun you
know you couldn't ask for a better match
from him he is about to maybe even three
nil areas of faruga what a performance
from origin especially after a tough
event in total steel yeah
wow and for the first time today we're
seeing Wesley so in trouble that's the
closest match so far on the scoreboard
it's 1-1 over there but mamadov one of
The Underdogs of division one right now
looks like he's winning according to the
evaluation bar we haven't followed that
one too much but we should just mention
that one is guaranteed to game four so
we will follow it a bit later we will
definitely get to see Wesley so in
action against marmadov game three going
on and Wesley so in trouble and so is
Ali Reza for Russia do you think alireza
is uh shocked at the level Arjun has
brought to this court final
would underestimate archon I think
Arjuna has shown phenomenal performance
but definitely going into the match many
would have picked alireza as a favorite
on paper but the match has gone on to
show that you can never underestimate
Arjun and it looks like alireza is
staring at the face of a match defeat
here and we have a winner already in the
quarter finals Magnus Carlson in the
world number one
he plays a draw in game three against
Alexa Serana to take that match after
only three games that means Magnus
crawls and he stays on the winner
bracket Alexei Serrano will be knocked
down to the losers bracket to play
losers round one tomorrow Magnus Carlsen
goes through to the Winner's semi-finals
tomorrow
what a way to start for Magnus ah he's
looking good and it could have been 3-0
there as well Magnus took the draw from
a position of strength so uh yeah
unfortunately Serrano ran into Magnus on
a uh on a good day and it's hard for
anyone even at their best to compete but
it's nice to see uh the one of one
looking strong yeah it could not have
gone better for Magnus and I think when
Magnus has lost the game to any player
when he plays him the next time he just
comes back with such a Vengeance yeah
and I think that's what he did today he
wanted to this was a grudge match for
Magnus and he proved his point yeah
beating someone once isn't Revenge I
think it's quote from Magnus Carlsen but
today he beat him twice and could have
won three games yeah sound defeat for
Magnus Carlson for Alexis Runner it
doesn't get any easier that's what
happens in the Champions chess tour you
may lose a match it's double elimination
you're still in the thing but it's
likely that he's gonna face off against
Ali razor farugia so you lose the Magnus
in an open tournament you say oh you got
to play me great you're gonna go beat me
and then go play them again now he plays
likely I'll raise the fuja yikes tough
matchups ahead yeah Magnus carlsbon will
face the winner of this matchup in
tomorrow's winners semi-finals and that
looks like it will be Arjun all right
guys see those two played each other a
bunch of times last season on the
Champions chess tour yeah and uh often
Magnus Carlsen was his Kryptonite Eric
icy uh the only one who could stop him
at times so uh this position back to the
game we do see all of those black porns
advancing look at the left side of the
board those black pawns marching down
them and uh I think it's inevitable one
of them will eventually cost white
material or become a new Queen and some
of the viewers at home might be
wondering why is the position so
hopeless for white it's actually level
material white has a rook black has a
knight and two pawns but it's just the
pure domination the pure control that
black has on the queen side and once the
Black Knights step out of the way of
those pawns they will continue their
inevitable advance and meanwhile white
has no counter Play No source of
activity for the remaining pieces White
Knight feeling a bit stuck not able to
jump over to defend White's other Rook
which is finally mobilized not really
going anywhere anytime soon
so with a bit of care with a bit of
control such as this last move using
that pattern that Robert used uh earlier
porn dominating that white Knight's uh
yeah this shows real uh look class from
aragaisy that's so nasty because it's
completely unnecessary it feels like he
can just push his pawns up the board but
he doesn't want to give his opponent a
sliver of Hope That Knight on F3 it's
not going anywhere those pawns can be
pushed in a few moves and so a great
Play It's just complete dominance from
our generic Garcia I love that move F6
just making sure that Knight's got look
at this it goes to the rim it's not
going anywhere from there it's already
been there yeah that night and it's
gonna start retreating hopping around
trying to find a better circuit I think
here at Regency will just take a timeout
defend that F6 Pawn maybe use the black
king the only piece that isn't doing too
much right now and yeah white is playing
without a couple of pieces look at that
sad white Rook completely controlled uh
by the Black Knights nowhere to go and
uh this one should be a matter of
technique as they say it's also 30
seconds against six minutes which
doesn't help at all I was looking at
Nora there with a coconut drink in
Panama that looked so nice jealous at
all I love it I love it it's quite cold
in Norway as you guys now know
it's uh yeah not looking warm on the
position for foreign
struggling to find a way back into the
game
it's uh just really tough it's been a
really hard day for farouza super hot
and he's gone Knight cheat too he wants
to find the way to the center of the
board he wants to come on to F4 D5 try
and create pressure on F6 also make sure
that black spawns on the queen side find
it difficult to advance it is winning
for Arjun but he needs to show some good
technique here he needs to find a way to
push those pawns it's not over till it's
over and I still think there's work to
be done here guys yeah sophisticated
move though from Eric I see that black
Rook Landing in the center of the board
again controlling any night jumps
stopping the White Knight jumping in and
wow Eric icy blow after blow tactically
so sharp today this move shocked me I've
got to say at first it looks like this
Pawn can simply be captured but Robert I
think that's a tactical justification
yeah so the pawn is captured black will
not recapture on C3 the Knight will drop
back to B5 you may think oh why just
give me your pawns but there's Knight C3
check and it Forks the king and the Rook
that will scoop up material for black so
this is a devil devastating tactic in
arjun's favor he is seeing everything
he's being preemptive he's making sure
the White Knight couldn't get anywhere
and now he's deciding to pounce when the
moment is right yeah and now simply this
Knight is going to capture this Pawn
it's not a fork this time because the
white Rook moved but uh it's simply a
check driving the white king further
away and these pawns are just gonna
start rolling you can push them now you
can push them later it's uh it's gonna
be inevitable impossible to stop them
now and from Russia is now playing with
seconds left on his clock to save this
game to save this match it's looking
hopeless for the young Frenchman
can tell body language we sometimes read
into it sometimes we have to ignore it
but here ferocent knows that no chance
12 seconds it's just been one of those
games one of those days
what's gone wrong for him today is it uh
his own fault so to speak or is it just
Arjun has been
crushing it today archen's been on fire
he's been tactically alert he's played
great prophylactic move being stopping
his opponent's activity he's shown great
technique even this one just just in
three moves getting a winning position
the a pawn marching down the board all
those ideas with the queen that we saw
in the earlier games just brilliant play
from start to finish he was never in the
back foot he was never worse throughout
the match so a very controlled win here
by Arjun and Robert I can see how
impressed you are on your face by these
moves from arigaity I mean every move
has a purpose in his game right now he
just traded Rooks and you're often told
well if you have fewer Rooks where you
shouldn't trade he's saying these past
pawns are storming up the board I do not
want to give my opponent any counter
play so if the white Rook that's on C1
could jump over the Knight maybe there
would be some chances to land a few
checks and give an opportunity to stop
the pawns but not from the front it
seems that if you just bring one of your
Knights either one back to the E4 square
with check then the pawns are running by
themselves it's as clear-cut as it gets
our generic guys see every move in this
game has felt extremely accurate yeah
you can start advancing I think even
either of them at this point but uh yeah
these pawns aren't going to be stopped
anytime soon I'm surprised at how easy
Arjun made this one look
and again logical moves will wrap up the
point like you say it's rare at the top
levels of Chess to play uh kind of such
a smooth game not allow your opponent
any counter playing six seconds for far
Asia we're expecting one of these
Knights to land with a check I'm not
sure which one's better they both look
very strong to be honest but Arjun he's
doing the right thing he's sitting on
his hands not rushing he knows this is
the critical moment he knows he's
winning just one or two accurate moves
and he'll reach that Finishing Line now
he's in calculation mode he's trying to
figure out which Knight to give the
check with and uh then which Pawn to
push
so uh yeah a matter of time but I
regardless he has three minutes that
should be sufficient to calculate his
way to that win
six seconds seven or four Oliver
that is probably not enough to save this
game
what a move again
seen everything and we have to show the
justification here he's actually giving
up his night because the black pawns are
just too strong and uh let's jump in
actually well we're gonna see it on the
board this Pawn is about to promote the
white request to stop it and the other
point other Pawn joins one of them is
going to become a queen and game over
three notes game over RJ and Eric icy
takes the match he goes through to the
winner at semi-finals where he will face
Magnus Carlsen also winning his match
today congratulations Magnus
thank you what has today been like a
crushing start to the Champions chess
tour season
the uh opening the in the second game uh
but apart from that it went uh went
quite alright
and you've said before that beating
someone once isn't Revenge you did lose
to uh sarana in the The Blitz World
Championship do you feel like you got
some Revenge uh beating him in a
crushing style today
I didn't think about that uh I mean I
ended up winning the um bubbles after
all so but that's fine
and we know you're playing from Canada
actually quite early in the morning so
what has that been like to to wake up
early and start playing the Champions
chess tour
no it's not that bad I mean we started
11 there and uh I haven't been here long
enough to to sort of get 1100 on off uh
European time so that's that's okay and
did you get some help from the chess Pro
the chess bras actually in preparing for
the games
uh well I mean getting things set up and
such but uh theoretical preparation was
um sorry lucky
okay got it now uh mine is we I can see
you guys working together here you do
stay on the winners bracket uh we know
you were
um well looking forward to testing out
this double elimination format so how
happy are you that you get to stay on
the winners bracket now
yeah
dispatch for uh not the uh
easy either but um
and Magnus you're a huge sports fan what
do you think of the Jersey on the wall
behind you and the other sports
memorabilia sitting around there
yeah it's it's nice
um
I don't know as much as I should have as
I should about Rocky though so I'll have
someone
and tomorrow Magnus winners semi-finals
against Arjun arag I see someone you
played so much last season on the
Champions chest or what's going to be
your plan against uh Arjun
uh I haven't really thought about it
um
I'll definitely much at a time and I
thought it was probably more likely that
I'll play the other reason instead but
[Music]
um
um yeah origin is very strong it is uh
as its best as he showed today so both
easy yeah and finally new uh format with
the clocks as well only three seconds
increments how did you like it
um it's a little bit unusual uh
especially when you get to time
scrambles and uh
like I did in the second game I was like
a little bit
it was a bit unusual for me that I I
wasn't actually able to to think much I
just had to play on on anything there so
I think it will take a little bit of
time getting getting used to it being
more of a sort of a
um the pure Blitz finish than
um
all right well mine is big
congratulations on a great start to the
season and the best of luck tomorrow
thank you thank you for joining us
Magnus Carlsen is one of uh several
players already ready for the Winner's
semi-finals he's gonna play Arjun Eric
icy and uh we have to get caught up on
results we do know Arjun aragaisi has
won his match against Borussia and uh
Hikaru Nakamura a draw and game three
means he is also ready for winners
semi-finals uh Wesley so I didn't see
Wesley so and mamadol was 601
surprisingly actually what happened
there he turned it around he was dead
lost it looked like he could barely move
a piece at some point mamadov in full
control but mandov cashed it in at the
wrong time went into an equal end game
and got outmaneuvered Wesley was too
strong in the latter stages of that game
some Wesley saw is in the lead heading
into a game four and that one do you now
hold him as a favorite to to win that
match before it even goes to Armageddon
I don't think that anybody is envious of
the task of beating Wesley so he's one
of the most solid players on the planet
so good luck to Ralph momentov because
Wesley does not relinquish the lead very
often
and we have three matches finished now
oh Tanya I mean how surprised are you
that three players have been actually
able to crush their opposition today
I think it's a surprising result for
sure as sirana going down in just three
games Hikaru winning in three games I
think it's still believable and then
Arjun that has been the most impressive
for me in this one Magnus mentioned
himself that he was actually expecting
to play alireza in the next one yeah
incredible
um David
um we didn't get to follow Wesley so's
third game here which was when can we
take a look at it yep let's uh try and
jump in at The crucial moments and uh it
was around here that uh mamador took
control he spotted this cool tactic I
must say after the pawn to G5 he grabbed
a Pawn on B2 black is material down he's
the exchange down Rook for Bishop but
this bishop is now poisoned if the White
Queen takes it then suddenly the black
porn pushes and two threats Unstoppable
threats one making a new Queen but also
Checkmate on the G2 Square later uh he
just got outmaneuvered simply mamadov he
cashed in at the wrong moment and in
this end game Knight versus Bishop
Wesley survived to this point and it was
eventually the H Pawn that won him the
game the black king moved the H Pawn
started rolling and mamadov panicked he
couldn't deal with its advance so Wesley
turning it around but with a bit of luck
on his side
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion
play against Dr Wolf as he explains
everything step by step points out
strategic ideas and alerts you to your
mistakes
train with him and go over your past
mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices today
so much action already today three
matches finished after only three games
we're going to take a look at everything
that has been happening but if you're
not a subscriber here's the twitch break
[Music]
I would not have bet that ewanka the
three matches would have been finished
after three games some dominant chests
that we've seen already today yeah it
has been incredible I mean what an
emotional rollercoaster I have to say
and wow
wow wow wow it's just unbelievable I
mean the way that Magnus Hikaru just
outclass their opponents was just
something else yeah and who has
impressed you the most so far I think it
has to be Hikaru Hikaru actually just uh
completely calmly neutralized kukash
kukash really came at him quite hard and
Hikaru just made it look so easy you
know he just said okay fine you're gonna
kind of come for me and my king that's
not a problem I'm simply going to repel
it and just win material yeah win it in
the end game and then also Arjun erag
icy winning three games against the
super strong alireza fujah he now goes
through to face Magnus Carlsen in the
winners semi-finals tomorrow what kind
of confidence is Arjun bringing to that
match tomorrow it feels like Arjun is
just benefiting from all the luck you
know in this match it did really
resemble that faruga just imploded in
those critical moments and when you have
a match that feels so easy you're just
gonna feel like your hopes are just in
the ascendant yeah wow what a day and
it's not finished you guys because one
match is yet to be decided Wesley so
against Ralph Mama Dove game four is
coming up very shortly here we go game
two you guys wow peace sacrificing and
yeah your first instinct was what he's
given up a bishop his London Bishop Big
Choice from originator guys tonight he's
attacked the diagonal this check can be
blocked by Black's Bishop version
leaning back though and it's over and
here we go game three I like to move
Queen to B5 he's eyeing that D7 Square
from where he can hit the Knight on E7
the B7 Pawn is soft uh so brukesh here
really creating his chances
he is uh knocked down to the losers
bracket uh for uh tomorrow Hikaru
Nakamura states on the winner is bracket
together with Magnus Carlsen and Arjun
aragaisi but who will Hikaru face
tomorrow in the winners semi-finals it's
either gonna be Wesley Seoul or Ralph
mamadol and if it's going to be momondo
he will have to win game four Wesley so
it's all by one point
and with a draw Wesley's Soul goes
through to the winners brackets so what
is it about foreign
he's so clinical with these things once
he takes a lead in a match he knows his
task is cut he doesn't want to create a
mess on the board he keeps everything
under control this is going to be a
tough one for Ralph yeah ranked as
number 102 in the world in classical
chess how big of a surprise is it
actually that Ralph momentum is even
here in the first Division I think for
those who have been following chess for
a long time they're not surprised
because Ralph mometto is insanely
talented especially at quicker time
patrols he knows his theory well he
plays very quickly and he is tough as we
just saw in that game he was better
against Wesley so in game three he just
slipped at a critical moment
and uh what's going to be about for him
now he's gonna
have to win this game to take it to an
Armageddon what do you expect from the
game David it's gonna be tough it does
depend on the opening Mama Dove is very
very dangerous with the white pieces as
Robert says he knows his openings inside
out he needs to catch Wesley off guard
take him out of his comfort zone as
early as possible if Wesley gets a solid
structure a solid position maybe a
simplified position like an end game
then I think there won't be any chance
so Madoff he needs to keep it
complicated and go on the attack he's
done it before he did knock out
napoleonishi from the planes
and let's take a look at the the bracket
three matches in the quarterfinals have
finished one match is yet to be decided
and the winner is from the quarter
finals go through to the Winner's
semi-finals while the losers they are
not knocked out they are only knocked
down to the losers bracket to play
losers round one tomorrow we do know
it's gonna be Alexa is around against
alireza Fusia in one of those matches
and it's gonna be gukesh against either
Wesley so or mamadolf and mamado he has
to win now game four it looks like right
now we will see Hikaru Nakamura against
Wesley so in the winners semi-finals
tomorrow and that's a prestigious one
must be for any American it's a rematch
of the chess.com Global Championship
semifinals where Wesley so took down
Hikaru Nakamura to make it to the final
invention to win it over Nielsen so you
know speaking of Revenge Hikaru Nakamura
has that on his mind I mean already on
day two week can get the match up Wesley
so against the car Nakamura that would
be incredible yeah and they've got so
much respect for each other both of
course in the world's Elite for many
many years now they've played each other
in the global Chess Championship they
played each other in one of the Grand
Prix finals last year Fida Grand Prix
and uh yeah that one is too tough to
call both of them incredibly hard to
beat and both of them super fast so uh
that would be exciting but first Wesley
needs to overcome Ralph mamadolf that is
exactly what he needs to do a draw in
this game with the black pieces means
that Wesley so stays on the Winner's
bracket it's must win for Ralph mama dog
but he does have the white pieces
and here we go and uh before we can
predict the opening before Kai can get
it right again it's one E4 and Wesley
he's not going to back down from his
normal repertoire hizzy standards uh
standard repertoire his default setting
is Rock Solid anyway and I expect to see
maybe the Berlin defense if given the
opportunity one of the hardest nuts to
crack in uh terms of chess openings what
will ramadov go for now it's strange to
pause on move three I've got to say uh
either you bring your Bishop out which
is what nearly all top players do
nowadays or you have maybe a sideline up
your sleeve but uh you've got a surprise
Wesley you've got to do it now and there
are some adventurous lines in the scotch
the problem is Wesley so plays the
scotch opening from the white side so
you're not going to catch him off guard
there we get the Italian a slower start
but maybe there will be some tricks up
rough moment of sleeve yeah at least
with the Italian game we do often see
all of the pieces still on the board at
move 15 move 20 and even beyond that so
uh going for maximum tension here
and it is one of the main lines of the
Italian game will just slow down I
expect go to a maneuvering phase Tanya
who do you think that's this is going to
favor I completely understand the
decision to go for the Italian the
Spanish would be a bad idea because it
would allow the Berlin as you mentioned
Scotch not a great opening against
Wesley with the Italian the reason that
Ralph is taking time in the opening is
that you have to kind of decide your own
setup how you want to place your pieces
it's all about the little pawn moves do
you commit C3 do you go shot Castle do
you first bring out your knight to D2
what do you do with the a pawn and all
that will determine the kind of middle
game that Ralph will get all he wants to
do is to make sure that he has
flexibility that is why he's chosen to
move C3 always eyeing that Center break
on D4 he wants to first if cost finish
his development and I'm expecting a
developing move right now bringing out
the night or going short Castle I like
this approach by Ralph in a
win-on-demand situation yep the Italian
game it wasn't in fashion up until maybe
the mid 2010s and suddenly everyone was
playing it suddenly everyone was beating
me with it and uh yeah it's uh it tends
to be a good opening in these must-win
types of situations however of course
Wesley so vastly experienced both uh
with white and with black in this
opening and mamadov doesn't look like
he's enjoying it on the camera I've got
to say doesn't look too optimistic about
his chances he still played very logical
moves black now castling white is super
flexible you can Castle yourself you can
delay that if you want to maybe maneuver
your pieces a bit further but either way
he's got to believe in his chances uh in
this game otherwise he won't get it
looking one of the most unpleasant
things in the Chess World is to play for
a win against an opponent like Wesley
saw he's just so hard to beat so well
prepared give him one opportunity he
takes it and doesn't give you a chance
he keeps everything under control and I
like that white hasn't committed a short
Castle move so now Ralph is really
thinking does he want to try to create
something on the king side now that
black has gone a shot Castle himself or
will he play a slower Italian with the
ideas the Thematic ideas of transferring
the Knight to the king side to G3 yeah
and that's one idea there's a bunch of
options you can go for while Ralph has
another slightly confusing long think
here this is the one that you're
recommending here Tanya it can happen
now or on the next moves for example if
you wait you can wait maybe by dropping
your Bishop back or by pushing a pawn
you could also try and tempt black to
play a useful looking move such as this
one just stopping any later Bishop pin
along this diagonal but now suddenly
white could use this Pawn as a hook and
uh perhaps try to start attacking and
look at what Ralph has done he's hoping
for a slip like this from Wesley of
course it won't happen Wesley's too
experienced he knows all of the ins and
outs of all of these plans for both
sides but Ralph drops his Bishop back
saying okay you commit first you show me
your hand you show me your plan and then
I'll decide where to put my pieces if
you push this Pawn forward I might well
start blasting open the king side and
try to castle with my king on the
opposite flank later if you don't commit
to that move at least I'll know what
what setup you're going for what you
intend to do so interesting kind of Mind
Games here and those are the questions
that Ralph especially is asking himself
right now and Wesley is deliberating
here because he has many attractive
moves he can just bring his light Square
Bishop out to E6 offer a trade pieces he
he does just that as soon as I mention
he could have first lit his Rook over to
protect that square but he decides let's
go for the trade if white has just spent
a turn going Bishop back to B3 now
Bishop takes E6 it seems like you're a
Tempo down from the white side so
there's no fear for black opening up
that f file instead Ralph castles but I
just don't feel this is the type of
position he won he's in must win
territory and I truly believe that
Wesley so may be the single worst
opponent to play when you need to win
Magnus Carlson needed to beat him in
classical chess in Vikings a he hit
magnets of the white pieces couldn't do
it Wesley was super solid so I just
think that Wesley he's too precise and
he does not play with any risk yeah and
this position looks like a dream for
black if we talk about openings and
their outcomes uh now you can just drop
your Bishop back this bishop is attacked
and at some point later you can aim to
break forward in the center it feels
like black is equalized effortlessly uh
light squared Bishops have left the
board and every piece trade will guide
Wesley towards safety at least for black
and uh yeah I think it's not
unfortunately been the most successful
of Italian games for Ralph but can he
keep the tension can he keep the winning
chances I don't think I want to face
Wesley in a must win situation I
definitely don't want to face him in
this position either because it looks
right up his alley it looks uh like he's
well in his comfort zone and once that
Bishop Falls black back Wesley is
already threatening to advance the a
pawn to attack the White Knight on B3 so
white will again have to spend another
Temple stopping that idea because if
black is able to advance further on the
queen side then you get more space with
the pawn jumping forward so once I think
Bishop to B6 happens white will have to
make the move A4 giving black the
opportunity to make that Central break
that we've been talking about with D5
yeah and it's surprising neither side
took time out to go for a ride of those
plans instead Wesley uh just takes a
time now to cover this Square for uh for
the white Bishop you don't allow any pin
you don't allow any uncomfortable
tension there of course white can't
Propel his pawns forward and go uh to
try and open lines against this hook
because White's King has finally
committed to the king side and he's
arguing that a knight takes Bishop type
of move will actually favor Black
because suddenly a semi-open file a
backward Pawn to Target if the black
Brooks can line up against it it might
well just drop off the board later
interesting decision and uh just Safety
First approach again from Wesley so
classy just preventing any Glimpse any
hint of activity for White's Bishop
and we see the pieces swapped off though
I think that gives at least Ralph
something to consider that in the long
term he has the bishop against a knight
uh the pawn on C5 not really a weakness
I actually consider it a strength
because white will never be able to push
that D3 Pawn up to D4 so what black will
likely do is just double or triple along
the D file bring the Rooks to the party
and start putting pressure on that
square so I don't think that immediately
white has any progress at least not easy
to make but down the road if white also
doubles the Rooks behind that pawn maybe
there are some eventual breaks
maneuvering of the pieces that can give
Ralph some hope so it's not an advantage
certainly not but at least something to
hope for you know it's some imbalance
and that's the most you can hope for
when you're trying to win a game you
just uh change the type of pieces you
have change the pawn structure slightly
and hope that long term that pays off
but uh yeah for now it's very much a
slow maneuvering game while these
players try to figure out their
strategies and first of all Wesley has
to defend that pawn on C5 probably with
a pawn maybe with this queen
he's just breaking open the center
targeting that D3 pawn and says come and
take my C4 Pawn not only do you double
up your own pawns but watch out for that
pawn in the center notice how the E4
Pawn gets weak and black will be able to
snap that up with his own Knight I love
this move it solves the problem of
having the double pawns for black and
now the ball's in White's coat and not
pleasant choices to be made here for
white yeah it's a dilemma already for
Ralph uh either you capture this Pawn as
we're pointing out there and black now
has a four versus three majority on the
king side in terms of Pawns meanwhile
White's double pawns don't make a great
impression here or this sad alternative
would be
um well what is the alternative it's
hard to come up with a move maybe to
drop the Knight back allowing a
symmetrical Pawn structure you have an
issue of this Pawn I guess you could
defend it and then pick up this Pawn
next for black uh for white but very
maximum here you just get symmetrical
Pawn structure and a dead quality and
that's being optimistic that's what
happens when you make one careless move
against a superstar like Wesley so the
move Bishop E3 such a natural developing
move attacking the pawn that was on C5
it seems at first he should have brought
his Queen up to the E2 square that way
C4 is in the threat then developed his
Bishop then connected his Rooks and La
that would have given him much more to
play for but look at Wesley he does not
even pause for a second he swaps the
Queens off and all he needs is the draw
he might even be the side for choice in
this end game with the healthier Pawn
structure it's going to be a four on
three majority uh and the King side if
it cut the board in half and for white
that four on three majority you got
double pawns you're not going to be able
to create a pass Pawn this is just great
for Wesley so you know I just love how
he instantly Hoovers off the Queens I
think most of us would be reluctant to
give away and Seed the D file but he
doesn't care he knows that The Rook can
infiltrate it's just one move and uh
soon The Rook will be evicted from the
black half just really calm eliminating
all the pieces eliminating all the
danger just classic Wesley so this is
amazing stuff I mean this queen shred he
doesn't want to give any chance to his
opponent the reason he decided to take
on D1 and then on e4 is that if you
capture the pawn on e4 if you just back
up one move and take on e4 instead it
allows the sliver of Hope for white with
the move Queen D5 centralizing the queen
putting pressure on black and if you
take that Queen well it's a pawn
structure that you will suffer in the
end game but Wesley doesn't want to go
through any of that trades the Queens
just again very clinical play when he
needs a draw yeah very clinical play and
we see here Ralph lamidov just Shuffle
his Rook to the side it's looking very
very good uh very solid for Wesley and a
bunch of moves here you can kind of
protect your Pawn your knight indirectly
you can just jump back with the Knight
if you're scared of it being attacked in
the next few moves you could even if
you're feeling ambitious push this Pawn
forward I'm not sure how much risk where
to leave so will take now but yeah it
does feel like he's a big favorite to
make the draw he needs and I do see some
questions in the awesome twitch chat if
you are watching on the chess.com
channel on Twitch some people asking if
this is the last game of today and it is
if Wesley so wins this game or it is a
draw then this is actually the last game
of today but the action continues
tomorrow with winners semi-finals and
losers round one and Ralph momodov he
did lose game three to Wesley so and uh
he was very upset afterwards
look at that
and this was his chance this game was
his chance yeah because he had winning
chances as well in this game
yeah it's more than just winning chances
it's uh he knows he had it in the bag
and it's so hard to recover it's not
just affecting that one game that he
lost it's affecting this game and you
can see on his body language he's not
feeling uh too happy with himself
because if he were able to at least draw
in game three he would have the white
pieces here in game four that would send
it potential to Armageddon and people
can't forget that in the chess.com
Global Championship Neil sarin made to
the final when he lost and became
runner-up to Wesley so but he almost
lost in round one to Ralph momento this
is not someone who just appeared on the
scene this is somebody who's been around
the block he's wrecking Ralph and he
knows that if he's playing his best
chess he can take down Wesley so in a
match so that is why he was so upset he
had his chance he was out playing Wesley
in fact throughout the match I don't
think he's really been worse except for
that one end game that David was
highlighting for the H Pawn started to
run yeah
very close and it's always more
heartbreaking when you know you are on
the brink of Victory if you could
outclass if you get outplayed then you
could have just accepted and that can
happen against someone as strong
especially so but he's had his
opportunity massive opportunity and now
he's got to do it all over again and uh
okay he's played some decent moves I
quite like what white has done in terms
of Pawn structure on the king side he's
pushed his G Pawn forward normally a
dark Square Bishop is well complimented
by uh pawns on light squares but still
an uphill struggle to create weaknesses
Flex very solid and oh a trade of Rooks
interesting decision giving away the D
file this time and it's all to push his
Pawn forward
talks about wrecking Ralph he's trying
to wreck the pawn structure sorry
getting the feeling that Ralph is over
pushing right now he almost feels like
he's going a little bit on tilt here and
not taking that much time making all
these very strong rash decisions of
pushing the pawn trading the Rooks on
the D file uh I think when we saw him
that upset on the screen it's also
because for the players who are making
that debut in the Champions Chester it's
really an opportunity that they've never
had before and they've been able to do
that this time because of the new format
which allows Grand Masters to qualify
and play in the tour so it definitely
means a lot and to have that winning
opportunity against the player like
Wesley it can be really frustrating
because you know if you have to win on
demand against him just how hard it will
be right now we're seeing by Ralph these
moves advancing the pawn G4 G5 to me it
seems more on tilt and more rash than an
actual try for a win yeah it feels like
minimum reward but quite a lot of risk
involved but then again draw is the same
as a loss for him so he's just trying to
confuse Wesley create some chances you
can't just sit there and beat Wesley
with a very stable Pawn structure uh
instead he's at least trying to change
again the Dynamics of the position you
balance things slightly and uh maybe we
can jump in because Wesley has paused I
thought his move was automatic I
wouldn't actually consider anything else
here for black other than capturing this
g-pawn this straggler in the black camp
but what else could he be thinking about
where Ralph's idea we should mention
after 0.6 Pawn is to recapture with the
bishop and again a bit of an annoying
pin but mostly uh it's all about
pressure on this E5 pawn and uh Wesley
what else could he be considering here
why has he stopped for the last couple
of minutes I think it's exactly that he
is trying to calculate a little bit
ahead to see how he wants to actually
respond to that attack on the E5 Pawn
it's not very pleasant to actually
sidestep with your Rook to the closed
file the close the file to defend your
own pawn and then allow White's Rook to
step forward so now not wanting that he
decides to take another decision David
he doesn't want to allow white to put
pressure on the E file he falls back
with the Knight on H7 that's slightly
surprising to me I'm trying to figure
out what's the idea is this not a pawn
Sacrifice by Wesley so after Pawn takes
Pawn this pawns defended by his Bishop
he answers your question we're all
looking confused okay Robert I think I
understand it so even though objectively
it seems it was a mistake if we just go
back if he had indeed captured on G5 and
that Rook E8 was the follow-up after
Bishop takes pawn and if Bishop takes F6
G takes F6 we see the evaluation bar if
you've got this position the board says
Ah it's level not a big deal but there
is this out past Pawn has H Pawn that
black needs to stop so in certain end
games with pieces getting traded white
may just be winning so Westie is likely
relying on and what he did in the game
is he sacrificed the pawn but said that
pawn I'm likely going to be able to
Corral it and win it later so let me
just keep the remaining punch structure
healthy for black and then proceed from
there I think that it was a mistake the
other line did not look particularly
scary but at least I understand what
Wesley was thinking and doing this and
he may just try to create a fortress
push his Pawn up to F6 brings King out
to F7 and maybe when the time is right
he can start pushing his pawns on the
king side and say that white is stuck in
his tracks no more progress to be had
something like this and as you say
Robert should maybe bring the Knight
around eventually this Pawn you can now
go for it with your king with your Rook
maybe
um it's not going to get anywhere for
now and black is still super solid but
being a pawn down you want to avoid it
if you can in an end game uh very
surprising we said that Wesley he's so
solid but uh yeah here he's making a bit
of a risky decision and the evaluation
bar does react I'm not sure whether it's
just because white is a pawn up so the
evaluation Bar says okay slightly better
for white right now but wow what a move
by Ralph mamidov he's going for it on
the other flank as well this could be
potentially very strong and a bit of a
shock to Wesley he's played B4 and this
Pawn is covered twice this Square by
Black's pieces for example after a
recapture black and even take with his
Knight but suddenly uh White has very
aggressive moves first thing Knight
takes Pawn is an idea The Rook could
also swing across I'm not sure which one
is stronger out of those two but uh
Ralph he's trying to give up the pawn to
get a pawn back and the more lines that
become open the more that will favor
whites ship and Rook so Wesley wants
none of that he just simply sets up that
solid porn wall in the center and Ralph
I think he's going to start stepping
forward why not this is where he has the
majority four versus three it's gonna be
hard to create passport here but at
least he's kicking away the black pieces
interesting stuff this is fantastic play
by Ralph to try to create his chances
and after F6 he has the option to
actually slide with his Rook already the
B file now the eve bond is supported you
defund your own pawn and you want to try
to push your pawns and gain space on the
Queen's side and with that H Pawn still
alive it looks like all the risk that he
was going for has paid off yeah I like
it I'm starting to like it I love for
white this Pawn does tie down a whole
night after all and uh okay he's just
solidified his Pawn structure with his
own Pawn looks like a bit of a kind of
hesitant move a bit of an indecisive
move but at least he has enough
imbalance now to have a chance of
winning this game what do you think get
right now Robert chances we will see
Arma get on on this very first day of
the Champions chess tour 2023. pretty
good chances I think that this decision
was one that Wesley might kick himself
for I understand it I can get behind it
to some extent because he thinks he has
a fortress an impenetrable setup he may
be down one Pawn but good luck to
getting to any of the others but as
we've been highlighting there are issues
on the queen side white does have an
extra Pawn on that side of the board and
black isn't just going to win this Pawn
on H6 that's a password that's going to
remain at the very least tied down some
of Black's forces to it so I do think
that this game will go on for quite a
while and that's good news for Ralph and
his winning chances yeah it's almost as
if Wesley was in a must win situation
taking that decision giving up a pawn
very very strange stuff and okay he's
pushed his Pawn to G5 so cutting the
coordination between White's bishop and
that pass Pawn on H6 black has a clear
plan now he's simply going to advance
the black king towards that loan uh Pawn
on H6 but again white has two moves
white has at least two moves maybe while
that plan happens how can he best take
advantage of the time that Wesley's
given him I'm still looking for ways to
push on the queen side it looked like
Ralph was reluctant to do that on the
last few moves White's Knight Waits
Bishop a bit stuck they need to improve
um Tanya do you see any plans here for
white I'm trying to work out if there's
any way forward any concrete uh moves
here one thing's for sure right you've
got to try and keep that eight six spawn
alive for as long as you can and the one
thing that white needs to do to make
that happen is to push the other age
Pawn once you go H4 you break this G5
bond which is stopping the connection
between the bishop on E3 and the pawn on
86 so it can really stay on the board
for a long time distracting black spaces
and once that happens you can try to
expand on the queen side I like the idea
and I like the move B5 kicking that
black knight away and then advancing the
C Pawn further down the board creating a
second weakness on the queen side yeah
Second Avenue for attack potentially I'm
also looking at White's Knight in this
variation you mentioned after it pushes
forward the black pawn will attack it
anyway so I'm not sure whether we flick
in this move and then perhaps go here to
attack this black pawn or perhaps go
towards the center but uh ideally we
want to land the knight in this on this
beautiful post on e4 but it might get
stopped by Black's Pawn advance so I'm
wondering do you go for it now in the
current position here at least it feels
looser for black to push this Pawn
forward to prevent White's night getting
in uh it could start hopping around some
really uh sweet juicy squares and he
does go for this very natural Move That
Knight was not doing too much and uh
okay he first flicks in H4 and G4 so he
has opened up once again the protection
of this Pawn
interesting stuff I'm stun to like his
chances a lot it's getting double edged
but that's what you need if you're
playing for a win all of a sudden black
is pushing those pawns forward uh the
f-pawn may go up the board as well and
don't be surprised if black starts
creating threats that Rook can slam down
in the D3 square at some moment so white
needs to act uh without caution you need
to play quickly because if you just
start making slow moves like bring your
king to the side to F1 things of that
nature it seems like black will be the
first to attack the pawn H6 protected
it's safe for now but it's not doing
anything it's blockaded so I think that
black is ready to strike yeah black is
ready to strike and uh Wesley I think
both sides just need to play quickly now
they both need to throw caution to the
wind and just go for it Wesley can't
just think of locking this down with a
fortress that doesn't exist anymore long
term white is still doing extremely well
so uh he needs to push pawns maybe land
that black rook in the heart of White's
camp and Ralph there shaking his head
kind of looking up it's as if he's still
dwelling in the past he's still
remembering that missed opportunity in
game three he needs to focus now because
he's played very well he's created
chances out of nothing seemingly and uh
it's actually Wesley who needs to come
up with answers in this uh in this exact
moment
and that's one of the hardest things to
do as a chess player is to forget what
has just happened especially when you
know that you had a big opportunity and
you let that slip to forget that to
leave that behind and focus on what's in
front of you is definitely a big
Challenge and in this format it doesn't
get any easier so we see a decision to
trade on before the big question to my
mind here is uh Robert David what is
White's idea if black does go F5 I want
to trap that Bishop on E3 I want to go
F4 your knight on D2 is hanging how are
you responding to F5 yeah Wesley hasn't
gone for it yet he's holding back it
feels as if he's still trying to play
with the brake on uh but you're right
Tanya this is uh on tap anytime you want
it for example if white does mess around
with seemingly kind of useful move but
not doing too much then this is
definitely going to be in one idea for
black uh the Knight suddenly has to move
just to create some squares for the
bishop perhaps to retreat but this is
really kind of uh not what you want to
see you don't want to start pushing
pieces back so instead Ralph continues
with the plan he initial did a couple of
moves ago Landing in tonight on e4 and
Wesley immediately lands his own Knight
on this very nice Square hinting at
simply grabbing pawns back we see the
issue with what Ralph did he brought his
Knight to D2 he centralized his Knight
how could you possibly complain about
that decision but when black played the
move Pawn G5 to G4 uh David Your
Instinct I think was correct to drop the
Knight towards the rim to attack that
pawn and induce the pawn up to F5
because if that black pawn were already
in F5 the Knight couldn't hop there
what's that Knight doing it's attacking
not just the bishop on E3 but the pawn
on H4 and the pawn on H6 all at the same
time black can bring the king up to F7
as well The Rook can still go up to D3
white is up a pawn but doubled pawns on
the C file not making progress just yet
I think Wesley makes it look easy
sometimes he made probably an objective
mistake by giving up a pawn but
practically speaking it's looked like
he's had no issue since then yeah if we
think about simple positions or end
games or certain positions where there
are simple plans Wesley I think he's
number one in the world uh maybe with
Magnus Carlson up there too it's just he
makes it look so straightforward as if
you know how did did you not see this
earlier how did you not understand this
plan he just uh he's so consistent once
he finds an idea and he's going for it
now it's very hard to hold everything
together for white I don't see how white
is actually hold on to that extra Pawn
you're threatening to take on H4 you're
threatening to land that Knight on F3
with a devastating check the only way
that I can see white creating any play
is to take advantage of the open a file
shift that Rook from the center now all
the way across the board go to A1 start
targeting uh the seventh rank the pawns
on the seventh rank the H4 Pawn is dead
and gone
bye bye I'm gonna give you a pawn back
and you have to activate those white
pieces but two minutes now for Ralph
five for Wesley it's not looking uh
promising in terms of a fight back
anymore just one or two slips and that's
all Wesley needs
well this is looking tough I don't envy
him in this position and the white king
is actually wide open there are plenty
of checkmating attacks if we go for uh
Tanya's line if we can just show a few
moves that that would lead to a forced
checkmating sequence let's say The Rook
slides the A1 the Black Knight takes on
H4 The Rook goes up to A7 great you're
threatening those pawns but in Comes The
Rook to D1 with check the king is only
one safe Square on H2 because the Knight
covers G2 the Knight hops into F3 of a
check and no matter where the King goes
up to G3 or over to G2 Rook G1 is check
and made so remember this configuration
with a knight on F3 defended by a pawn
once The Rook slides in it is going to
be a mate against the white king so I
think that Wesley has this all under
control yeah it's looking like Black's
pieces they're just coordinating so well
right now uh it looks odd in a way
because this Knight is paralyzed it's
stuck just blockading a pawn but uh the
rest of Black's pieces the rest of the
structure is uh perfect and wow we're
all reacting here in the studio because
Ralph is Maybe out of desperation
sacrifice to peace he's given up his
night just for a couple of Pawns and wow
okay he's created a pin this surely
can't work that's a one more pin you
just sidestep it defend your night on F6
go Rook to f8 and how does white
continue there I guess there's another
Pawn up for grabs this Pawn can also be
captured he's just gambling here Ralph
he knows he's in a must win situation
and he's saying okay I don't care about
pieces but uh I guess this Pawn will be
taken and the Black Knight steps back
defending this uh defending its fellow
here it's hard to believe I've got to
say that white has enough for the piece
but you do have three pawns even if they
are ugly double pawns and it gives you
chances because a lot of the other
variations you may not lose the game but
you're certainly not going to win this
gives Wesley some room to go wrong and
that's all you can ask for at this stage
of the game so objectively to the
evaluation bar saying come on what is
that but from Ralph a draw equals a loss
you might as well go down swinging yeah
I've got to say the more look at it the
more I like it he's definitely Taking
Chances but that's the only way you win
games at the top level you have to take
big risks and from a human point of view
Wesley will no longer feel in control
he's suddenly on the defensive and he
has to hold things together he goes for
tania's move defending his Knight here
but now another Pawn will disappear
there we go another Pawn drops and
suddenly black still on the back foot
I still believe Wesley's defensive
resources are more than sufficient here
but uh yeah from a human point of view a
good practical decision from Ralph if
they switched the times then Ralph would
have a legitimate chance but
unfortunately for him it is Wesley up
three minutes on the clock so worst
position time management not there for
you so Wesley does have things under
control he is so strong in positions
just like this yep and at least his job
is easier now Wesley just pure defense
he's done the hard work he's material up
with this Black Knight extra Black
Knight but Ralph he's going for all the
pawns this is very greedy I've got to
say but uh will the great pay off uh
Black's Knights once they coordinate
will actually form quite a devastating
attacking threat against the white king
and actually similar patterns to the one
Robert pointed out earlier might occur
on the board later if white gets greedy
and goes with his Rook to capture that
black G Pawn uh in the near future first
Ralph just advancing and trying to
improve to the maximum and then he'll go
Pawn hunting they are fighting to save a
spot on the winners bracket to face
Hikaru Nakamura in the Winner's
semi-finals tomorrow the loser will be
knocked down to the losers bracket in
this double elimination format to face
go cash in the losers round one tomorrow
now you guys at home are fighting to win
an air things device keep sharing your
selfies on Twitter using the hashtag
chess Champs preferably in landscape
mode we want to know where in the world
you are following the action where you
are watching the chess who you're
watching it with and the most creative
selfie will get a signed air things
device Magnus Carlsen has signed some of
these devices and we will send one of
them home to a lucky viewer
and meanwhile the pride and joy of
White's position has disappeared that
past H Pawn the front one the h61 it's
disappeared not only that but another
set of pieces have been traded off so it
is currently black having a night White
having three Pawns in return material
equality the quality uh is uh not there
unfortunately that black knight once it
enters the game
should decide things in Black's favor
and it's happening on the next move you
can already start bringing up the Knight
to E5 and putting pressure on the F2
weakness by jumping onto D3 things are
looking super Bleak and that sacrifice
that we saw the Practical chance that we
saw by Ralph it was a measure of
desperate desperate times called for
desperate measures and everything I
think the knight jump by Wesley to F5 is
really what's sealed uh the deal in this
game yeah uh made some very impressive
night jumps in this one Wesley and I'm
surprised he's hesitating I've got to
say maybe he's just looking for the most
clinical way to kill off this game he
could just jump in and improve his
Knights even further he can maybe just
improve the black Rook but no he goes
for that white H Pawn with his King he's
already won one Pawn with this King why
not go for a second H Pawn and uh yeah
it's holding things together now for
Ralph maybe some drawing chances to
eliminate those two remaining black
forms if you get rid of those rook and
Knight vs Rook is a technically drawn
end game but at the moment it feels like
a distant dream and even a draw remember
not enough for him to stay in this match
and Wesley locks things down on the
queen side locks things down and I feel
like his camera is locked down Wesley
hasn't moved since the start of the game
he does that he puts his hand over his
head he wants to focus on nothing but
the board in front of him and right now
he's showing why in the end game you can
use your King as a weapon it doesn't
just need to be defended that King is
out in the open but it's going after
White's vulnerable Pawn so great
performance by Wesley so in this game uh
he'd sacrificed the pawn it looked a
little shaky but since then it has been
nothing short of a master class and the
advantage is only growing yeah
now he could just pick up a pawn with
his King right now I don't think there's
any mating ideas that black king is safe
enough I was going to say I saw Wesley
blink so he's not just Frozen there with
the camera he finally does change his
posture but it's too late for Ralph
mamidov he's just trying to swap off all
the pawns now Ralph and get a draw to
salvage some pride but Wesley is going
to take this match and continue in the
winners bracket that last black pawn if
it survives should ensure a win but uh
very minimum here as Wesley you could
just trade off everything remaining on
the board
and there we go he does want to end on a
high he does defend that black pawn
Black's King still caged but the Black
Knight now will relocate and that will
be the beginning of the end
and for Wesley he doesn't want to
necessarily win this game sometimes you
look at a position you look at the
evaluation bar how could Wesley make a
choice completely winning if he sees a
three-time repetition he's taking it
because all he wants is to make it
through two of the Winner's semifinals
he wants to play hikar Nakamura tomorrow
so the win in this game it doesn't mean
anything to him let's just secure the
match yeah we saw that from Carlson and
Nakamura that professional approach both
of them took draws in positions of
strength in the third games of their
match just to secure match Victory it's
all about the next round the end goal is
to win the ethics Masters the end goal
is not necessarily to win this game so I
think you're right Robert I've seen
Wesley do it plenty of times before
take the safe approach and meanwhile the
black Rook
starting to get to a normal active
Square eventually I don't really see any
hope here for white uh to win this game
he's advancing with his King maybe
hinting at some Checkmate attacks
against the black king you've got to be
slightly careful if the white Rook steps
up there's a mate in one threat if it
slides across to H7 the black king is
trapped but you do have a move a
valuable move for Wesley to break this
construction I'm expecting the Black
Knight to jump back check hit the white
king force it away and no more cage for
the black king actually even after the
check once the white Kings does step
forward white is still threatening or
made on eight seven so what black wants
to do with this check is give a check on
D4 as well and keep checking that white
king yeah there's always a glimmer of
hope as long as you've got a Checkmate
threat on the board so we did see a
couple of tracks the Black Knight wait
that is not legal don't fall into it now
it's still there the threat of course
Wesley has spotted it and the repetition
it begins
and uh I think Ralph can only avoid the
draw now if he goes forward with the
white king but that would also be
playing for a loss he knows his chances
of uh progressing in this match are gone
but now it's Wesley who doesn't go for
the draw surprise I was about to say you
predicted the future but no he's playing
on I'm shocked because he doesn't need
to win this game he could have just
ended with the repetition instead he
brings his King back and maybe he's
enjoying the fact that he's a better
position because in the three prior
games it was really deadlocked in fact
in game three Ralph mahmetov had the
advantage so for Wesley perhaps it's a
moment to enjoy before he goes and plays
akara Nakamura tomorrow
yep and often on the first day of
tournaments it's nice to play a long day
I know it's tiring but you feel fully
warmed up you feel kind of back in the
zone so uh Wesley's kind of pushing this
the long game here I feel will benefit
him in days to come and uh meanwhile
Ralph just keeping the pressure on
keeping an eye on that black C6 Pawn not
gonna help but uh he's trying now
wrestling's down to 24 seconds is he
regretting not just repeating the moves
and wrapping up the match just get out
of here take the draw and move on
um yeah surprising what's Wesley
thinking about 15 seconds and only three
seconds increment remember 10 seconds
okay he made the move there he does give
another check he's still on top of that
type of repetition if you kind of uh
perpetually check that white king I
think we're gonna see it now David I
think the Knight will jump back to D4
we'll jump back to E6 if required and uh
surely a drop but no he plays for the
win again he came going Wesley so what
is he doing this is Wesley 2.0 but it
just feels so unnecessary right now it
feels like you're playing for a loss if
anything and remember if he loses we
will see Armageddon is there a chance
mamado will win this game still Wesley
still has to go quickly crazy for that
to happen but he's made some strange
decisions and okay he's getting checked
back to the edge with his King the white
porn is advancing he's down to 13 when
he had the draw in his hands yeah now
you have to calculate like White's Brook
could slide across and offer a trade and
I think it's fine for black there but
some risk involved and okay Ralph is
gone for this suddenly white has two
past pawns Rooks are off the board that
black knight is a great blockader under
control still for black should be a draw
once that black uh Pawn drops off the
board but uh Wesley he played it a bit
close to the line there he took some
risks unnecessary once and surprising
from Wesley so because he doesn't do
that in events where he really needs to
win and so when he doesn't need to win
he's suddenly deciding to take that risk
but you might be right David it's day
one he's just saying let me get into
tournament shape I'm gonna win this
match and I have an objectively better
position he's about to be a draw the
Knight checks the king it's going to win
this Pawn on D7 and then the last Pawn
is stop we see Knight in King versus
King you cannot win that it is a draw
and that means was this song moves on
wow it is over after four games Wesley
so wins this matchup and the
quarterfinals he stays on the winner
bracket to face Hikaru Nakamura tomorrow
in the winners semi-finals Ralph
momondov is knocked down to the losers
bracket and will play go cash tomorrow
and the losers round one feels so harsh
to say loser is about these fantastic
players but that's double elimination
where nurse back then losers bracket
yeah you can call it the lower bracket
it makes you feel better but no matter
what you lost today's match you only
have one match to spare if you lose
again you are out of this tournament so
tomorrow's a new day and hopefully a new
result for those who lost in today's
matches yeah and Wesley so he is one of
the favorites in the tournament he
finishes off with a draw in this game
winning one game today to win the match
and this game was there any drama
happening David there was and Ralph did
try his best full credit to him for
Taking Chances and at least attempting
something attempting to throw Wesley off
balance and I want to compliment uh
Ralph's Choice here by giving up a piece
this is very difficult for any human
player to give up material but you have
to take your chances you have to create
threats and give your opponent a chance
to go wrong it had already gone a bit
wrong for Wesley so but he'd recovered
he'd stabilized and we were pointing out
already some nice variations for black
including going for the white king some
potential mating attacks Ralph tried to
change the momentum another important
factor when you're trying to win games
by sacrificing a piece but unfortunately
it didn't work and he created a pin
double threat here a pin along this
diagonal and this black porn on E5 about
to drop off but Wesley now
as usual uh he defended everything he
held everything together and uh Rook
takes Pawn he just dropped his Knight
Back The Rook defends the Knight the
Knight defense every Square the white
Rook wants to use and just two moves
later we saw at the beginning of the end
black was able to Hoover up this pawn
and slowly but surely guide the game
towards safety
but oh wow
what a move I love it wow what a move by
Ralph mamidov he's going for it on the
other flank as well this could be
potentially very strong and a bit of a
shock to Wesley Ralph is maybe out of
desperation sacrificed a piece this
surely can't work
wow all the games day one and champions
chat store 2023 have finished how are
you summon up Tanya
I mean for me the star of the day was
definitely Arjun defeating alireza in
those three games and we saw so much
drama and dominating play for the three
matches Ralph was the big surprise he
really had an upper hand and I think
that was slightly heartbreaking for him
and then of course Wesley doing Wesley
things keeping everything under control
it was truly a day filled with Fighting
Chess and drama yeah what will be the
reactions in India to Arjun eragasis
huge performance today everyone's going
to be super excited he also plays Magnus
tomorrow and that is something we all
really look forward to arjun's had tough
results against him but over time he
sort of realized that he needs to stop
fearing Magnus so much and he has had
better performances ever since then so a
big match coming up and I think tonight
is about celebrating for India seeing
Arjun go through and of course gokish
gets Another Second Chance in the losers
bracket yep that's the great thing about
double elimination everyone gets a
second chance let's take a look at the
results from the quarterfinals today
Magnus Carlson a dominant win against
Alexa Serrano winning two games were you
impressed with Magnus today Robert it
was Flawless it felt like Magnus was at
uh throat from the beginning he never
gave him a chance so impressive display
from the world champion and then Hikaru
Nakamura also winning two games against
gukesh what can you say about the
hikaru's play today David it was a
classic Hikaru smooth polished very
classy and uh very controlled kakash did
throw everything at him but
unfortunately it just wasn't enough
hikaran top form yeah and then three
wins for Arjun Eric icy against the
other teenager Ali Reza Borussia to win
that match Wesley so getting that one
game win he needed to knock Ralph
mamadol down to the loser's bracket and
let's take a look at the bracket double
elimination format this season on the
Champions chess tour means Magnus
Carlson stays on the winners bracket to
face Arjun arigaisi in the winners
semi-finals tomorrow Wesley so and
Hikaru Nakamura and the other winners
semi-finals also to be played tomorrow
that is best out of four rapid games on
the losers bracket Serana against
farusha that is best out of two rapid
games and momedov against gkash best out
of two rapid games I have to ask you
Robert Wesley so against the cardinal
American battle you did hold us a
favorites in that one I think it's a
complete toss-up I know that's a cop-out
it's a cliche but Wesley so is so
difficult to beat and for akara Nakamura
if he's thinking about that semi-finals
loss at the global Championship that
could kind of make him feel like he
needs to win lose some objectivity so I
really see that both players having
their chances they've had impressive
days today hikara played the better
chess but tomorrow is a new one yeah and
then Tanya Andrew garci he was crushed
by Magnus Carlsen in the final of the
Julius bear generation Cup last season
but he must have so much confidence
going into that semi-finals against
Magnus tomorrow 100 and also the fact
that he made it to the finals of the
Julius bad generation cup that is a huge
deal as well and I think it's going to
be very critical for Arjun to just
forget that he's playing Magnus and try
to keep that aside he needs to keep
control on the clock makes sure that he
doesn't fall a lot below a lot behind
Magnus uh come up with some good opening
ideas he needs to do everything right
because that's what you need to do if
you have to beat Magnus yep
that is one of the winner semi-finals
tomorrow the other one Wesley so against
the car knock him around we're joined by
Wesley congratulations on winning your
first match of the Season Wesley
all right thank you very much it's uh
good to see you guys again very good to
see you two sitting at home in Minnesota
I can see Wesley what has today been
like
sorry
what has today been like in your match
against Ralph mamadov
oh it's been pretty tough I think Ralph
uh came to the match very well prepared
prepared uh I didn't get anything in
game one but I almost managed to Swindle
him and came to his surprise me in the
opening but I applied pretty solidly and
great game 3 was clearly the turning
point because I prefer this line in the
king's Indian
but
he didn't know what to do but I I
blundered upon a bit one after that uh I
guess black had the initiative
but I was able to outplay him in the end
game
but that was nice and and game four was
pretty safe I guess
how do you feel about going into matches
being a big favorite like you were today
Wesley are you comfortable being named
the big favorite
well I don't think that was a big
favorite I think maybe I'm the favorite
but in a Four game match anything can
happen and uh and they're both played
really well
so you know I mean it's nice to
it's nice to play a good match today and
be able to push it through but
I mean of course tomorrow I'll have a
half opponent and Hikaru
and I'm sure he'd want to have hit the
wrench from the global chess
Championship a few months ago yeah so
it's going to be uh going to be
interesting uh I think today I was able
to get some positions that I like and I
was able to push it through
and Wesley uh well done uh on today's
match of course uh it's great to see you
back on the tour what are your goals for
this season and what do you think of the
new format
thank you yeah I I think
I I think I uh you know knew already
what my goals for this season is
we had we had that thing
but uh
yeah you remember my girlfriend wait but
but it's nice I mean
it seems that there is new rules a new
format within every year but I like the
time control with the three second
increment and I like I like much formats
even though I would prefer it to be six
games or eight games
but uh it's all it's all good at the
same time there are
far less events this year than last year
only six
uh so it's going to be a
it's going to be interesting I hope to
do well tomorrow because I was watching
the play in the other day and so
difficult to qualify in the top six so
uh I yeah I hope to
to do well and if I don't qualify then
just do the play in but it's going to be
interesting with lots of new players and
lots of Grandmasters uh this year and
it's it's certainly tougher than
Lafayette yeah I remember I'm very
pleased also to be seated for the first
event and playing the same band of
Magnus
I remember one of your goals Wesley was
to win one of these Champions Chester
events this season what chances do you
give yourself in this one with both
Magnus in here uh Hikaru that you will
face tomorrow
yeah you know I mean I'm hoping that one
of them would
fall early
it didn't happen but uh
now I just just want to play Good Jeff I
mean I'm still trying to focus on
classical chess this year
but uh but I like playing this uh
playing this online events I like this
format I'm
not the best player in Blitz uh there
are many other better players than me
but with 15 plus three I think I can I
can compete
and Wesley congratulations so much on
today's win it was amazing to see you
fight the difficult third game and do
your thing in the fourth one uh so
firstly congratulations and I want to
just look ahead to tomorrow and ask you
a little more about that because it's
such a big match for us it's sort of
like the two big heavyweights playing
against each other you're facing Hikaru
tomorrow what do you think you have to
do well to get by uh tomorrow's match
and is that something that you're
worried about what Hikaru brings to the
board that you need to watch out for
well first of all I have to understand
the format so tomorrow is just a four
game match yes
okay just a four game match winner
semi-final and yeah it's best out of
four uh rapid games just like today
okay so so it's it's nice uh
yeah I mean hiko's been doing very well
online uh winning speeches championship
and all those uh title Tuesdays so
you know I I think I have to be at my
very best to compete against him even
the match in Toronto could have uh could
have gone really either way
so uh
you know Hitler plays online every day
basically and he's got yeah one of the
highest ratings in chess.com
uh I think I need to get you know good
positions out the opening positions that
I enjoy playing and uh try not to
blunder anything and try to
keep up and
keep up on the clock uh today my time
management was not the best and I'm also
very impressed by the fact that you know
hikar won today in in three games and so
I'm going to be checking that and
hopefully
you know
hopefully history repeats itself like
from before yeah what a match is going
to be we're already looking forward to
it uh Wesley big congratulations on your
match win today and good luck tomorrow
as well
yeah thank you guys thank you so much
for joining us
Wesley so one out of four winners uh
today who stays on the winners uh
bracket tomorrow he will play Hikaru
Nakamura and we're gonna announce
another winner one of you guys at home
who shared a selfie on Twitter
and here we have the winner it is
D is it yeah watching from work with my
party
topper Hopper
Hopper Cooper
cheering for Wesley PS would love to
know my workplace air quality well Mike
now you can we're gonna send an air
things device to you is going to be
signed by Magnus Carlsen and you can use
it to measure air quality in your home
air quality has been good in the studio
today it's been the very first day of
the Champions chess store 2023 season
how are you sum it up Robert it hasn't
been good it's been amazing we've seen
some of the best players in the Chess
World kind of crush some of the up stars
in The Chess World and then we also saw
some mesmerizing finishes Wesley so kept
us on the edge of our seat he makes it
through the semis to face off against
the car Nakamura that'll be really
exciting tomorrow yeah and tomorrow we
will lose the first two players David
two players on the losers bracket they
will lose their matches and be knocked
out what do you expect from day two of
their things monsters I think any player
who is at risk of going out will want to
go go out in style and I expect more of
the same those in the losers bracket
they're shorter matches just two games
but I expect more of the same today
everyone was going for the full point in
every battle and uh yeah I can't wait to
see more I'm so excited and we have to
remind you guys there is also a division
two and division three going on in the
area things Masters I'm just quickly
taking a look at some results that Neil
dubov has lost his match and let's knock
down to the losers bracket in division
two you can check all of those results
if you headed to chess.com and join us
again tomorrow for day two of the air
things Master as the action continues
and two players will be knocked out
thank you so much for watching today and
I'll see you again tomorrow bye for now
oh
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign